Matt Gates has filed to remove Kevin
McCarthy as Speaker of the House oh boy
aren't we excited apparently Kevin
McCarthy cut a back room deal with
Democrats to get this continuing
resolution through and it's an insult to
everybody who believes that we should be
fixing the problems of of the corruption
in Congress and not just layering them
on but this is basically what's
happening Matt Gates is trying to get an
uh trying to make bring about an end of
the to the omnius spending bills where
they just put 5,000 Pages we're all
spending the money we're buying it all
vote Yes or don't he wants to bring on
single subject spending Kevin McCarthy
is basically playing games they're doing
what all members of Congress always do
where they basically say well we'll just
uh we'll keep funding it the way it is
and we'll we'll we'll deal with these
things later in response to Matt Gates
threatening to remove Kevin McCarthy as
Speaker of House of the house or to file
they're trying to remove Matt Gates so
it's getting uh uh pretty wild and um
well we'll see how this one plays out
Donald Trump was in court today for his
lawsuit he called the the uh he called
the judge a rogue and we'll talk about
that apparently they've dropped some of
the claims against him but it is going
to be fun we are down here in Miami so
talking about Mar Lago Trump and how
they're lying about the value of his
properties will be a blast and then of
course we've got Jamal Bowman over the
weekend what he he pulled a fire alarm
and then he called everybody Nazis then
he said no I I didn't call them Nazis
nazzi you can't call people Nazis and
then someone found a tweet where he
called Michael NOS a Nazi uh this is
going to be very very interesting get a
bunch more stories before we get started
my friends head over to
timcast.net
now if you would like to attend and for
elite members at timcast if you're a
member we're going to have a Meetup and
I guess you call it supper not dinner
it's a little early 3: p.m. we will be
meeting up with all of you guys to hang
out it'll be a blast so click join us at
timcast.net
everywhere if you really do like what we
do joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more it is an honor we have
Dave Ruben Mr Florida man Mr Florida man
Mr Florida man that's right welcome to
the free state of Florida Tim how do you
feel it's wet it's wet and it's good you
that's what she said you look moist and
dewy from our humidity and our freedom
it actually brings out the uh the
essence of people the freedom is
palpable it's it's pretty sweet man I
mean I get it it's good in West Virginia
I get it but come on it does not get
better than this I disagree what could
possibly be better what could possibly
be better than this place oh man uh the
mountains we don't have mountains here
that is the one thing the one thing that
I do conc on the Florida thing we're
we're pretty flat St I look out my
window I see mountains mountains aren't
bad we have uh we have we got freedom we
got water we got freedom we got beaches
I'll give you I'll give you the beaches
and a little bit more freedom than we
have you know West Virginia is doing
pretty good though we're we're fighting
a good fight no you guys are doing all
right I got I got no problem with West
Virginia but I'm glad to see you here in
the Free State of Florida this is going
to be a blast it's going to be a good
week so thanks for coming man yeah and
and the other Florida man is here
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings I am the Polish Florida man and
it is good to be back the Democrats
can't tell the difference between a door
knob and a fire alarm while the
Republicans are tearing each other to
shreds and you love to see it you know
the deal if you like the shirt that I'm
wearing right now with Trump Tupac you
can get it on the bestp political
shirts.com
and since last being here I got fully
demonetized so I launched a new business
that is a vitamin health store on we are
change. shop I've been able to help a
lot of people check that out Ian you
look like you're also on a little
personal health Journey there you have a
little Sparkle in your eyes that you
didn't before than for no how you doing
man I feel great man I'm I gained about
20 lbs over the process the last two
months three 2 and a half months or
something muscle and fat I feel great I
smell different I stopped wearing
deodorant there you go sear for a new
kind of deodorant muscle and fat as
opposed to what water what else is
there bones and skin yeah bones bones
got crazy my bones are huge you gain you
gain nuts you look great you look I'm
serious your transformation is something
that could inspire a lot of people I see
it I thank you for doing it oh awesome
well I'm glad you noticed I got a
question for the Florida man before we
get going too far you know how like when
a fish is in water it's swimming it
doesn't know it's in water it's just
there when you're in Florida do you know
you're the you're Florida man oh I'm
aware absolutely it's it's in your veins
it's it's genetic it's it's it's like
autism you can't get rid of it it's here
when when you're when you're in Florida
you are 100% Florida man you the vibe is
here right you got to remember I lived
in La before this so I was in enemy
territory and especially during Co I'd
be walking my dog without a mask on and
people would be yelling at me and
yelling at my dog where here I walk
around and I have my Flor a hat and I
keep a picture of me and Dan santis on
my phone in case I get challenged by
anybody like oh you're the new guy from
Cali cuz they think you're a communist
or something like don't worry I'm with
this guy and it's just like everyone
here is Happy functional everything's
working here there's no crime it's all
good so you're always aware there's
business less taxes you have firearms
that you could actually keep on you and
defend yourself if you get attacked
without you know going to jail for the
rest of your life which is a which is a
big piece of mind for a lot of
individuals we and we have a story too
we shoot we we have a yeah and Ron said
that yeah yeah we we have we have a
story we might we might get to that I
really I talked about quite a bit
earlier was the uh uh the prank prank
anster they call him in Virginia where
he's getting people's faces freaking him
out and then he got shot and they lock
up the victim but for who was shooting
in self-defense Jerry said it was
self-defense they still put him in jail
so we'll talk about this stuff but let's
let's jump into the first story we got
big news ladies and gentlemen from The
Washington Post check it out Matt Gates
files motion to oust Kevin McCarthy as
house Speaker Matt Gates introduced a
resolution Monday evening to remove
Kevin McCarthy from his seat triggering
an expected INR party clash and setting
up a showdown for the house to decide to
depose McCarthy likely within 48 Hours
Gates and a handful of hard right
Republicans have repeatedly threatened
to go after McCarthy's speakership if
you relied on Democratic votes to pass
any spending legislation which happened
Saturday after McCarthy could not get a
majority of Republicans to support
various proposals to fund the government
with only GOP votes using a motion to
vacate a single person can force the
house to consider removing the speaker
McCarthy agreed to lowering the
threshold to bring in the motion to win
over enough support to become speaker in
January this one's going to be really
interesting McCarthy is basically a
Democrat at this point if he's now
teaming up with democrats for his
spending bills and working against
Republicans the question though is Will
Democrats now seeing an opportunity team
up with Matt gates to remove Kevin
McCarthy do you guys see what's going on
Twitter right now um Kevin McCarthy just
tweeted quote bringing on bring it bring
it on Matt Gates retweeted him just a
couple minutes ago and said just did so
the drama is unfolding on Twitter in
real as this video is happening right
now and and it's very interesting to see
what Matt Gates is doing here because I
I I think you know the long-term
strategy for Matt here is to probably
become the next governor of this very
beautiful amazing state after Ronda
santis leaves office in a few years and
if he's going to leave in in a fury of
fireworks and just public outrages and
storms this is the way to do it this is
the way to to get your name out there
and in our current kind of political uh
sphere where outrage cells and
controversy really is the lead this is
the way to get everyone's attention and
I think he's doing a good job at it as
of course this is an important issue
he's making an important stand even
though it is Republicans fighting each
other which they usually do anyway I
mean we all knew this was going to
happen right it took McCarthy what 15
votes to get the speakership in the
first place so like it was all leading
to this at some point I think most of us
and probably most of your viewers are
with M with uh Gates and spirit of
course like enough of the nonsense
spending enough of giving all the money
away to Ukraine and everything else like
can we take care of our border uh but I
hate to tell Matt Gates even if this is
just because he wants to be Governor The
House Always Wins that's how this
operates in Washington right like
McCarthy will stick around most likely
and even if he doesn't it's not going to
be Gates as Speaker of the House and the
Machine just finds a way you got to give
the devil his due we may not like it I
certainly don't like it I don't think
any of you guys like it but it finds
away that's why we always get into these
shutdowns frankly I would be for the
government shutting down right now and
not coming back for a couple years years
that would be fine with me but that's
not what's going to happen right they
extended for 45 days and 45 days from
now we'll all be pissed about something
else and something else will happen but
don't worry zalinski will get his cash
yep and the Republicans will bend over
and and bend the knee and take whatever
globalist policy that they tell them to
take and they'll implement it without
even any kind of doubt Kevin McCarthy
has been a lot different in His Kind of
Rain ever since Tucker Carlson left Fox
News and I and I think really there's
something to to note here when it came
to Tucker Carlson and Fox News calling
him out that that that whole entire uh
pressure on him is totally gone and
since then we have seen a totally
different Kevin McCarthy that really has
been uh not in favor of of of the people
and ruling in a way that hasn't been
benefiting anyone ising El isn't there
something super weird happening here
because Trump backed McCarthy Gates is a
trump guy I saw the Bas guys going after
uh Gates today because Trump is not
because Trump backed McCarthy so it
really creates some really strange bed
fellows like arrows start going in some
really weird ways and then did you see
Trump today after uh after the hearing
that he did in uh where was that that
was in New York right after the hearing
he basically was like well I'm not going
to go after McCarthy because he says
nice things about me which is That's
what everyone hates about Trump but I
get it I get it he can say anything I
think they'll always love him Matt uh uh
this this this was during the fight for
the speakership in the house Trump was
for McCarthy and Matt said no and Matt
said he didn't care I think this shows
Matt's principled I I I have tremendous
respect for the work that he's doing
it's about time somebody did it but uh
to be completely honest I'll just I'll
I'll soften a bit of what you said Dave
you're right I mean the machine finds a
way you've got all these snakes and and
and Matt's trying his best I posted a
picture of Copus when he said I'm trying
to change DC and I'm not and you know
people got mad they were like what's
what's the alternative I'm like I'm not
saying he shouldn't do it I'm glad he's
doing it but he's pushing a boulder
uphill and it is a long way uphill I'm
glad I'm glad he's doing what he's doing
he's one of the most effective one of
the best politicians we have if you can
even say a politician is good but he's
pushing a boulder up in well
philosophically what would you say I
mean I think if McCarthy was sitting
here he would say hey there's this giant
swamp there's this giant system I mean
I've interviewed him and talked about
this I think he would say you can maybe
get some incremental things like the
machine is so the swamp and the Deep
State it's so there's so much there and
they can almost never get anything done
right like the Democrats are just pure
evil and the Republicans are kind of
just a little less evil so I think
McCarthy's argument would be in essence
it would be hey maybe we can do a little
something spend a little bit less or get
a little money moved to the Border or
something and he I think that's really
what he's saying right now that would be
a win where basically what you're saying
is Gates is just trying he's throwing
the hell Mary knowing there is no flying
F chance that it's going to work but it
it is good if you're actually
auditioning for another job I would say
by the way I don't think it's not
necessarily just Governor I think he may
just want a a spot on network TV I don't
think he wants to be Governor I I I I
would imagine that probably if if this
if there was further future Ambitions
Senate makes more sense Governor brings
him to the state whereas he's in DC
right now right so that's a that's a
shift I don't you wouldn't want to take
right uh well if he likes being in
Florida I mean he is a Florida guy like
he likes being in Florida why not come
home to Florida I mean DC is an absolute
disgusting Cesspool of scum I I I I
wouldn't I wouldn't immediately say it's
just about uh a a job prospect they're
trying to remove him they're threatening
to expel gates for what he's doing I
wonder if this is why Thomas Massie
tweeted out this is like yesterday um he
I fear this is the quote tweet from
Thomas Massie I fear the attempted
attempting to vacate speaker McCarthy at
this juncture is a bad idea that would
lead to worse outcomes for conservatives
signed the only still serving co-author
and co-sponsor of the motion to vacate
Speaker Boehner so he he went through
this before and apparently think
McCarthy anyway uh Thomas Massie yeah I
don't know pretty sure he did but well I
think they did at the end but they did
him and Chip Roy ended up getting a
bunch of concessions that I think now
Gates is saying well you guys aren't
actually getting the concessions out him
but Massie to me Massie is the most
Libertarian anti-government guy we have
in government may you know Rand Paul's
right there too but in the house and
it's like if if that's what he's saying
there's probably he knows something
behind the scenes I wonder if it's he's
a afraid of what's happening to Gates
that they're going to now turn on Gates
and he's like we don't need interpart
conflict right now because the
Democratic party is trouncing Us in
party you in TR party right you don't
need Gates getting any friendlier with
AOC which every now and again they kind
of dig each other but I I I'll
appreciate I mean they were trying to
stop insider trading in Congress okay
I'll take it take our wins where we can
yeah yeah otherwise what they that Kevin
McCarthy has a back room deal to get
funding for Ukraine I'm I I I I I I
cannot believe that if you I I'd be
willing to bet if you went and just
talked to random people on the street
should we spend money on Ukraine they're
going to say no mostly a lot of people
probably say yes you know of course and
depending on which city you go to
they're going to have Flags everywhere
they'll say yes but I think a genuine
random sabling of a million people in
this country find 70 80 90% saying no
why would we do that but of course
Congress will do it why cuz Congress is
not beholding the American people
they're beholding to lobbyists hey as
Mitch McConnell said the number one job
of the Republican party is to fund the
Ukraine war the war that we're also not
in at some point do you think if you're
giving hundreds of billions of dollars
to fund a war you're in a war yeah would
that be a technical way you'd say you're
in a you know like eventually if you're
funding everything and also by the way
pushing the guy nukes a little closer to
World War III I mean that which really
is what they're doing right like at the
end of the day you could say Russia's
losing and losing and losing which
they're not by the way but you could say
that and at the end of the day when the
guy when the is about to hit the
fan he has nukes so who really is
winning and he and we're talking about
his doorstep yeah so it's just they've
not given any legitimate reason to us as
to why we're involved in Ukraine they've
not even tried to Now Kevin McCarthy
goes and makes a back room deal with
Democrats ignoring the Republicans who
he's supposed to be working with to get
funding for Ukraine wasn't it am I wrong
about this they they they put together a
clean bill but it didn't have Ukraine
spending in it and they're like no
Democrats were like we refuse I mean the
fact that the Democrats have become so
clearly the war party is just such a
perfect example of when I say that the
machine always stays ahead that's how it
always stays ahead because somehow the
parties flip in front of your eyes the
Liberals become conservatives and the
conservatives become liberals the
machine figures out a way to just exist
and continue do you think the people are
voting because they're afraid of Putin
or because they're just bought Oh you
mean our congressmen I don't think our
congressmen are afraid of Putin like
maybe Putin's got some dish on who's
like banging who and who's doing coke
and hookers and all that stuff but I
think it's they they figure one way or
another they get these people basically
to betray the United States and then we
you also have to remember guys like we
have such a nation of people who are not
paying attention in any way whatsoever
cuz they're addicted to pills or porn or
whatever or just distracted or don't
care or they're scrolling this thing all
day or playing video games all day that
it's just easy to just keep the machine
in operation it's actually not that
difficult we can all talk about it but
it's not that difficult to keep a bunch
of people stupid but I but I do think we
are seeing a generational shift a lot of
it has to do with Ron Paul that's how
you end up with people like Matt Gates M
because where Ron Paul was do know he's
in Congress he's saying no no no why are
we doing this very few people cared then
he runs 2008 creates a movement on the
internet a lot of young people grew up
understanding and hearing what he had to
say and a lot of these young people
shouldn't have heard it at all if the
machine had its way so I do think
there's a strong possibility and and the
culture war is a component of this what
the quote unquote right is in the
culture war is basically people who are
inspired by the ideas of Freedom Liberty
individuality Etc and now you're looking
at a deep State a bureaucratic State
desperate to stop a Freedom Movement of
some sort ining degrees it's prettyy
clear the people aren't being
represented in in congress the people
are disenfranchised people are pissed
off the price of everything is going up
and these politicians are getting richer
and richer every single year that
they're in public office when they're
supposed to be taking polit uh political
uh salaries and then but but they're
they they're millionaires somehow how
did that happen because they're selling
you out they're selling your country out
and you were right Tim especially about
Ron Paul he started of course the
original tea party the original tea
party was hijacked but the original tea
party SED the seeds for Occupy Wall
Street Occupy Wall Street brought a lot
of people together then of course it was
also co-opted but after Occupy Wall
Street we saw a huge shift especially in
the media narratives especially in the
divide and conquer uh kind of Arena and
and now we're really reaching a point
where people are like I'm sick of
politics I hate politicians none of
these people represent me the
Republicans are just as bad as the
Democrats the Democrats are just as bad
as the Republicans it's a unip party
screwing you over and I think a lot of
people are realizing it and that's why
Kevin McCarthy I think is more popular
than ever and or Matt Gates sorry excuse
me Matt Gates is more popular
than they both are honest I apologize
for that but but I got the tweets pulled
up here and that's why I'm mixing words
here but Matt Gates is more popular than
ever for a reason and and there's a
reason we reacted to this news the way
we did because it it does kind of
represent a sentiment of people just
being disenfranchised and pissed off I I
think one other thing related to Gates
putting aside Governor or whether he
wants a TV host someone is going to have
to be the air parent to Maga at some
point right whether it's because of
indictments or Trump literally falls
down the stairs or or just goes out into
the sunet or or Falls up the stairs
right exactly but whatever whatever that
thing is when when Trump is no longer
involved in this whole thing someone has
to take that thing and it seems like
Gates is basically saying hey I'll be
the guy to do that again it's kind of
weird because Trump backs McCarthy and
refuses to say anything bad about him
and then the Trump people were going
after Gates today and that that's also
makes politics so infuriating right but
Trump's just the Avatar of the anger
he's captured so somebody's so take the
anger so when Trump backs fouchy when
Trump backs McCarthy there's a lot of
people who are like I still think
Trump's the best bet but it means that
it is not about Trump this is the this
is the this is the thing that people
didn't realize I should say Democrats
didn't realized 2016 on they kept saying
Trump is doing this Trump is causing
this division like no no no no no Trump
is not the cause of he is a symptom of
the people in this country are angry and
like Michael who was it Michael Moore he
said Donald Trump is the human Molotov
cocktail they're going to launch into
the system and it'll feel good if you
sto there his statement was fantastic
coming from a human keg you know but he
then goes on to say for a few days or a
few weeks but then they'll realize and
they didn't realize no he was wrong the
people chose Donald Trump because he was
just an avatar representing their anger
that means as time goes on it may not be
Donald Trump it could it could be a lot
of different people so long as you're
true to what the point is and the point
is yo we want accountability in
government well there was make America
great was really cuz you're talking
about there's angry Maga and then
there's like functional Maga and like
I'm afraid that if it's the anger that
got him elected that we'll see another
anger representative in the future maybe
not even from Maga and that things could
get really bad well look you can kill a
man but you can't kill an idea right for
Vendetta and that's the idea and I think
I think Gates kind of sees that that
this the Trump thing will not exist
forever how old is Trump he's 79 78 7 78
right he's no spring chicken again so
regardless of where this ends out
whether he's president again or anything
the man will not exist forever so Gates
is seeing the writing on the wall I mean
Gates I like him a lot too but like he
is a politician so he's in the system
too he's he's not in as a politician
right now to not be a politician actor
right he's in the politician to figure
out what his next steps are and if he
sees wow there's a movement that the
leader kind of getting old and someone's
got to take over like he's kind of doing
what's right for him I'm not even
begrudging him that I think it's just
worth noting Victor Hugo once said
nothing is more powerful than an idea
whose time has come and I think we're in
that particular time where there are
multiple political Paradigm shifts that
are absolutely huge that we're living
through right now it's very exciting but
also it's also very dangerous at the
time because as Ian mentioned it could
go either way yeah you could we got to
focus the magga laser on something
creative like graphine like
reindustrialization United States
everyone drink take a shot because if if
we don't Focus the magga laser the
Chinese Communist party will focus it or
the world economic Forum will focus it
and get people to fight each other and I
feel like that's what's been happening
for 5 years is that P people are
obviously the world is attempting to
manip at our government and our people
and they are and I I think it's more so
you know you have that Meme where it's
uh they're trying to make us fight
amongst ourselves so that we don't
actually challenge the system and the
corrupt and uh half true that Meme goes
back to Occupy Wall Street where you got
a bunch of people saying the 99% and you
know the big Banks screwed us over and
there's a rich guy in his office on the
phone he says introduce identity
politics m y what I see is they tried to
figure out a way how do you make it so
that it's no longer about the wealthy
and the poor but you make it so that the
poor people fight each other identity
politics you get a bunch of people on
the left to start attacking people based
on their race of course the right will
defend themselves who wouldn't defend
when they're being attacked namely when
they go after like white people and say
white males and all that stuff and this
creates division so it's funny to me
when we then see leftists pushing the
meme that they're making making us fight
amongst ourselves when it's like yeah
there's America a constitutional
republic that has values Norm and a
rights and then there's the weird culty
Marxist garbage you're introducing you
are the scop what they're doing is the
manipulation yeah they're the Pawns in
the game they're they're the useful
idiots and they don't realize it all the
kids that were out there burning down
their neighborhoods and burning down The
Pep Boys and the target like they were
doing it to themselves and not even
realizing it but you know when you talk
about the the uni party as two as one
Florida guy to another it's one florid
Florida man to another um this place
that we live in this is pretty freaking
functional there is nothing going on
here unless you guys can think of
something that I don't know about that
is not right in this state in terms of
what a functional government well hold
on I was uh I was driving dinner what do
you got a gator a gator jumped out of a
river sna the beanie what there was like
four Ines of water in the street which
proves climate change absolutely we're
working on climate change we're we're
very close to the water here you know so
it's a little more complex we're going
to make Ian eat the bugs and then
climate change is going to be over you
were you were sarcastic illustr my point
we can't it rained a little today right
you know people will be like well
there's a lot of traffic in the Miami
area now well yes we did get about
300,000 new people here and we're
building incredibly fast so I totally
agree with you on the unip party thing
and that the Republicans just blow and
suck and all of those things but in
micro places in different states and
that's the beauty of federalism it's
working like this place is hyper
functional has brought in a million
people everyone's flourishing we have
some issues there's some issues around
uh insurance right home insurance
because we have two massive we had a car
category five hurricane Ian two day a
year ago two days and we had another one
ealia not too long ago so there's some
there's some like human issues but in
terms of the functioning of the state
and Law and Order and the the uh you
loot we shoot thing you know that
hurricane and demolished Southwest
Florida last year demolished it there
were there was no looting zero looting
that literally would not have happened
there was a little Skirmish outside of
the Miami Heat
um Stadium but then cops came in right
away and then they booked people for
blocking traffic immediately and then it
was over there was Skirmish or I love it
when people and I saw a lot of Maga
people doing this because they're always
going after Florida right now uh when
when it's Miami you know it's spring
break and in Miami Beach they get
thousands of people from other places
and they get real drunk at night and
they brawl in the streets and it
happened for like two nights and I saw
all these people going after dis santis
first off the governor is not in charge
of what happens on every street in every
city every moment uh but I tweeted
something like you guys do know that if
this lasts another day Fort Lauderdale
by the way in Miami Beach Democrat mayor
some of the few Democrat Mayors in the
entire State you know he's going to get
involved and then two days later the
National Guard was there like that's
what I'm saying this place while the
while the DC version of the uni party is
deeply corrupt and backwards some places
are doing it right and it's not just
Florida I think this is the best example
of it I'm a little biased but I do
believe Florida is the Alamo it is the
the last free kind of standing place in
America that's standing up fr a lot of
individual liberties a lot of Rights a
lot of uh you know just just the basic
principle of you being able to keep your
money that's a very important principle
that a lot of people don't have in
California and in New York and that's
why I think I I kind of want to go
against your point Tim a little bit I do
think a governor is more powerful than a
senator on a local level because I do
believe say he wasn't more powerful I'm
saying we were you were talking about
Gates you were saying I don't think he
wants to be a governor be a senator yeah
you you you can you can have a lot of
power in Florida or you can have a
little bitty power in DC but
I would a governor is way more important
than a senator mainly because of just
how much involved they are in everyday
life just how much they could make a
difference when it comes to carrying
firearms just how much they could make a
difference when it comes to tax policy
and uh I I truly do believe Matt Gates I
think would be a better Governor than a
senator and I would hope he becomes the
next governor of Florida but I'm saying
is when you're a senator or member of
Congress you can actually have an impact
on immigration and when you're a
governor you can't kick you can't Deport
people you don't have the authority and
you can only voice your strong opinion
we did send a whole bunch of people to
Martha's Vineyard which keeps them in
the country so I I do appreciate the
move because it's a sanctuary City they
say they right but the issue is while it
does
create I suppose uh notice of the issue
creates awareness yeah all solve the
macro is all it's doing though is
bringing the people in and then sending
them deeper into the country you know
what a governor does do very is very is
how they handle natural disasters I was
going to ask you guys talked about the
hurricane a little bit and and the you
loot we shoot message right off the bat
curbed it so like I think a lot of our
political instability might come from
natural disasters we might think oh it's
about people and money but like if
there's a global flood we're going to
get tens of billions of or millions of
people are going to flood the unit you
know we've already seen it on the
southern border so I think but they're
look it listen listen yes if there are
disasters and things like that in other
parts of the world but the issue is if
literally nothing happens anywhere else
in the world and we keep making the
country better they will keep saying I
want your stuff uh yeah but I anyway but
the real point is natural disasters I
think it's very important how we handle
those things and you could even call Co
a natural disaster even if it was built
by humans it that reacted as if it was a
natural plague look you know how well
Dan santis handled the Hurricanes
because they couldn't get him on
anything like the media is waiting for
the guy to literally just step in the
wrong puddle or or anything else and
idalia there was not I I did not see one
article that he failed on anything you
know in during Hurricane Ian the santel
causeway it's a threemile bridge that
they built from Fort Meyers to the
islands over there it was blown apart in
five different spots it would have taken
the federal government or any other
state government literally 5 to 10 years
to rebuild they had cars going over that
thing in three weeks I went over it and
you could not even tell the sections
that were new versus the sections that
were old because he basically walked
went there and said hey we're going to
get the best Engineers here we're
cutting all the red tape build this
freaking thing and they do it and that's
so we don't sometimes I think the thing
that the Santa suffers from actually is
that we don't know what to do with a
competent Governor or compet a competent
politician we just we just don't know
what to do it's like whoa we're doing
everything right hot damn let's talk
about this uh we have a story about
Donald Trump from Politico the crime is
against me Trump slams business fraud
trial apparently before the trial he
said that the judge was a rogue and the
prosecutor was racist I don't know what
he meant by that is it because she's
black and he's white or something but
either way what we're seeing from this
trial is absolutely Bonkers it's now
advancing I I guess Ian you are saying
something that they they've dropped some
of the uh uh uh claims against Trump
that's what Trump said at a press
conference right after he walked out of
the courtroom he and his lawyers started
talking and said that because of the
statute of limitations uh they dropped
or they they're no longer pursuing like
80% of the case and I think that's a
rough estimate I think he made those
comments inside of a Wendy's when he was
screaming yeah I think he went to
Wendy's right after the the court
proceedings and did another uh PR where
he was talking about how the was is that
like Giuliani going to the Four Seasons
but it was the Four Seasons that was
like uh like a garage or something no no
he he usually does Trump usually and
he's really good at this he does these
kind of PR stunts right after a lot of
these Court proceedings where he goes in
public places and public restaurants and
and buys everyone food and um he he buys
Goodwill and essentially has that a lot
of times he walks on that bill by the
way that's happened multiple so I want
to I want to address this because we got
some Florida men here you know the judge
said that marago is worth around $18
to20 million and this is 172 Acres of
beach to beach Palm Beach property now I
don't know what kind of place you're
you're living in Dave yeah however
whatever you must have bought living
down here it's got to be worth based on
the judge's estimate 50 bucks 100 bucks
something like that so um it's
completely so let me just say clearly
because I've hit Trump a lot lately and
I got a lot of Mag angry I mean all of
these cases are pure this one
is the height of because it has
nothing to do with anything political
it's purely to destroy the man right and
the crazy part about this is if you if
really the the the goal of all of these
things was to get him out of politics
you'd have to leave him with something
you got to leave him with his businesses
so he can get out right so the idea that
they're going after him on this and also
you know when you buy a house you've
bought properties when you buy a house
you don't just you can't just make up a
number this house is worth $40 million
you get an appraiser there is a system
in place and it well depends right if
you don't want to sell and someone comes
to you and says I want to buy your
property I think the value is you say
sure but the idea so it's 17 12 acres in
West Palm
Beach not West Palm Beach I made the
same mistake what pal oh it's in Palm
Beach proper right right right Beach to
beach yeah I have you been there I've
been there like it's it's a little bit
kind of getting old and they could fix
up a lot of stuff and it's probably not
worth what Trump wants it to be worth
but it is easily easily worth $80
million there is no real estate agent no
no I'm saying at at the bare minimum
probably closer to like 120 something
like that more um I don't know about
that
you for $20 million yeah but you have to
remember the market and you still and
you have to find someone that can buy
the thing so it can be worth something
sort of in our minds but someone that
really at this point with interest rates
the way they are and everything else
that would buy thing the point is it's
not 18 we're agreed on that neither one
of us know whether it's 100 or if they
section this thing off acre acre lots
yeah he's getting he he's going to get
300 400 million for it but I don't know
that just dead acreage yeah there there
there's some uh covenants requiring it
to remain historically or something like
that which does diminish the value but
right now the the there's a house next
door that is a third acre for and and
it's substantially obviously the house
property is substantially smaller 30
some odd million do right right right
insane insane they the guy's easily off
100 million I think we could say that
like some I think I think when you add
the fact that it's a business that it
generates 25 million per year is the is
the estimated Revenue combined with the
real estate the tennis courts and all of
that you've got a functioning business
at $25 million if you just had a
business that that ran at $25 million
You could argue your business worth 250
million why so so here's the here's the
way I phrase it because Kyle kolinsky
made this post where he was ragging on
Trump saying it's not worth this it's
worth that guy's still doing it he went
nuts on this one that guy and he said
it's it's it's it's it generates 25
million per year it's worth at most $75
million all you got to do is break it
down this way forget the real estate
value which is17 and a half Beach to
beach acres in Palm Beach okay let's
just say a business let's say you have a
business that makes $25 million a year
and someone comes to you and says you
you make $25 million every year okay I'd
like to buy this off you I think it's
worth 75 million your response is going
to be so what you're paying me two years
up front to sell my for the rest of my
life 20 25 million a year that's the
stupidest deal I've ever heard maybe 10x
if he says 250 million you're thinking
like I get 9 years of work upfront with
that money I can do a lot of things so
if you go to Trump and you say minus the
real estate it's only 75 million
absolutely insane you add that business
onto it you end the 17.5 I think Trump's
assessment might might he's at he's at
400 to 600 might have been a little low
depending on on on on how you want to
imagine it because if you were to break
it apart you could argue that value but
the but the crazy thing about the story
is they're arguing in this fraud case
against Donald Trump in New York and in
Florida that he undervalued his property
to get favorable or he overvalues his
property to get more money on loans
that's that's the opposite of what
people do with fraud they they say their
property worth less so they pay less in
taxes it would also be the fault of the
bank right like most people get loans
when you get when you buy you buy a
house for $100,000 you might put 20
grand down you get a $80,000 loan but
the bank comes in and appraises it they
don't they don't just magically you
can't just write a number out and be
like give me cash so yeah this this
thing is all complete nonsense uh the
fact that so there's not going to be a
jury trial you heard this they're not
going to be a jury trial because
apparently his lawyer forgot to check a
box on the form don't I don't know about
that you have a jury you don't have a
jury of your peers in New York City you
have a whole bunch of crazy leftists
that will of course automatically no
matter what happens no matter what
evidence is provided automatically say
Trump bad Trump jail well someone could
double check it but I think they're now
like saying that that they didn't check
a box that's what's going to happen
either Trump's lying or the judg is
lying I think the strategy here ask
yourself why why would Donald Trump
actually show up for this court case
when the judge already issued a summary
judgment dissolving the Trump
organization they want to file an appeal
so they don't want to waste their time
with a jury that's pointless it's going
to cost them more money all of that
stuff's a waste of time they get their
ruling run it through file the appeal
get the lower court get get the lower
court reversed yeah that's what I think
is happening as well because it it
doesn't make sense to have a jury trial
the judge is going to be deciding here
we saw a video of him today and he uh C
clearly really likes the the camera
really likes the Limelight but but all
of this happening here just to take a
step back there's politicians that
literally killed American teenagers
there's politicians that go to Jeffrey
Epstein's Island and you're telling me
we're going after this guy because he
overinflated the property value that he
had what this is after investigating him
for so long this is what you have on him
are you freaking kidding me I will say
this you get these these Democrat types
that are like we are holding people
accountable I mean are you saying you
don't want accountability my response is
if you come to me and say I can choose
between investigating Epstein's Client
List and Donald Trump overvaluing his
homes I say I don't care about Trump's
homes please investigate ab's cist they
still have not released this they're
still not doing anything related to it
but oh boy they're mad about Trump the
price of Trump's properties yeah how
many years ago did this freaking happen
this is ridiculous this is stupid this
is not in the public interest and this
is clearly the weaponization of the
justice system to destroy have idea to
clean this thing up I have an idea to
clean this thing up the timcast
operation's going pretty well you got
like 7 businesses you really you got to
you got a skate park indoors you're
doing a lot of stuff let's find out
about this 18 mil timcast moves the
operation down to Florida you running
thing if we can get Mar Lago for $18
million D deal I will take a I I will
take a half a billion dollar property
for 18 million I bet I can go to any
bank and be like I selling it for 18
million so be like I will finance that
oh you said 18 billion 18 million go go
for it do you think are they giving you
the just the flat land value appraisal
when they said 17 they're not even
accounting for there's no such thing
like not not that CU otherwise it would
be a complete tear down I don't think
anyone's making that ARG I got an idea I
have an idea here's what here's here's
my proposal to counter Democrats I I say
we all give Donald Trump blanket
immunity if he releases all the EPS
information and launches an
investigation into I've seen I I I will
I will go as far to say I will I will uh
I will give give Trump a full pardon on
literally anything he has anything he
has ever done if they actually
investigate and bring out the
information that
and and you might be why would the demat
that's a Double L I'm saying Trump does
when he gets elected when Trump gets
elected my my pitch is I think the
American people should all just agree
yeah Trump we're going to sign this
document all the American people agree
you are immune for any past wrongdoing
ever done it's gone you are immune okay
and now go after epin and you may be
saying but what if what if Trump's on
the EP list what if what if he's
involved I'll be like we we what if he
committed some very serious crimes or
fraud you're going to let them get away
with all that absolutely we go to drug
lords and gang bangers all the time and
say we know you did this evil thing but
we're going to make you immune if you if
you expose the leaders and the people
facilitating this so I whatever you
think of Donald Trump my point is this
when they come out and they're like we
want to hold Donald Trump accountable
for crimes I mean you're not saying you
want him to get away with it are you
like bro I will let him get away with it
I will clap for me having done it if it
means they go after the real criminals
if it means they go after the people who
were were trafficking children yeah
absolutely do you think the world would
be a better place and assuming both of
these would make it better if the hunter
Biden the bidens were completely exposed
globally and everyone knew or if Epstein
and and gilain were globally exposed and
everyone knew that's a good question
prob they probably connected absolutely
because Epstein it doesn't just go after
the Democratic families he also goes
after the entire establishment he also
goes after the entire banking sphere
which was involved here as we know from
the latest JP Morgan settlement that
happened as of course JP Morgan spent
tens of millions of dollars trying to
settle this out of court when in reality
the the the facts of how they were
complicit here is absolutely
mind-boggling you have to understand
that the American government for over 30
plus years used your tax dollars evaded
and used and abused this system to
traffic and hurt thousands of children
some of them as young as 7 years old
with your money this is ridiculous this
is infuriating there's so much
corruption and and when you look at that
EP thing he doesn't just go after the
puppet Biden family he goes after
everyone involved here and there were a
lot of different people a lot of
celebrities a lot of banksters a lot of
people behind the scenes that we're not
even aware of as of course Biden here he
he's just the flesh suit that the
globalists are using to screw you over I
got the vibe that Epstein was one of
gain's boys and that she has a bunch of
those dudes and he was just the one that
got caught cuz he's an idiot or he just
went too far and but she's like the the
Kingpin like the the Lynch pin well
where is the list where is the list
right with a judge it's sitting in a
locked box somewhere with the judge who
lot of information kept away from the
general public that judges are saying is
is too controversial for the general
public to find out about and therefore
needs to be kept away from the people
finding out so there'll be a freedom
information act at some point what 30
years from now and everyone's dead
or down just like they do with the JFK
files that still aren't released 6070
years yep 6 maybe even then I I I think
we have to understand here the
government will never tell us the truth
and we have to always imagine the worst
and then times that 10 because it's
probably a lot worse than what we could
even imagine with what really happens
behind the scenes because with the
Epstein stuff we're still just
scratching the surface to how corrupt
and utterly disgusting this entire
system is and uh there's another article
here that was just published by The
Daily Mail showing uh just the true
depths of this corruption that is titled
Senator Diane Feinstein's death leaves
her daughter wrangling over breathtaking
$102 million property fortune and $62
million private jet she used to visit
her mansion
salary I feel so bad for what's her
daughter's name let me look that up
right now I feel I feel so bad for her I
mean you're minding your own business
one day power of attorney over your
Senator mom and then you wake up to
inherit $150 million in properties the
amount of work she's going to have to do
aot she's going to be in meetings with
lawyers oh I just feel so bad for her
inheriting this this this vast vast
swath of Scrooge McDuck likee wealth
when Diane when Diane Feinstein got into
the senate in 1826 what were they paying
at the time does anyone know what was
salary it was food what year did for
real what year did she get in she's been
in well she was the mayor of San
Francisco but what year did she get in
the Senate probably 82 something like
that like what were they paying at the
time cuz the mayor of San Francisco
wasn't paying much maybe she had a
little family money but 100 100 million
bucks in the plane I'm I'll look into it
yeah let's get some numbers how many
children do you have to hurt to acquire
that money that's what that's what
people should be asking themselves with
these politicians because that's that's
who did she sell what did she do I'll
I'll tell you what she did did what she
did was I trading it's like exactly what
happens is a bill is introduced and it
says something like we're going to ban
widgets widget company comes by and says
hey this is really bad for us it's going
to cost a lot of jobs we don't want
widgets banned and then the politicians
like oh but they're going to introduce
this onto the floor which is going to
cause a stock to drop so they put a
bunch of put options on widgets the bill
gets introduced stock TR stock price
goes down they cash out then they say no
we're not going to vote on this one it's
gone and then the price goes back up
what's the uh isn't there some crazy uh
percentage that Nancy Pelosi has played
the market at like she trades better
than 900% of all day Traders or
something like that whatever % it's it's
something like really no literally by
like 900x like it's so someone could
check me on that but like how the hell
did she become worth all this money how
did Gavin become worth all this money
all of them right it's like that's why
they want to get in Congress they're
like it's it's just for if you're a day
trader and you want to get rich you get
get into Congress and then you you're
rich yeah Feinstein 30 years in Congress
she joined in '92 1992
$130,000 salary their salary from 130 is
now up to 174 right
SO3 million you put your salary you put
your your your cap taxes or your 80 cap
taxes into a savings account a high
yield and then with compounding interest
after 30 years you have $150 million
yeah you could and you could do it
depend it depends which way they carry
the one I think
right well that's all MERS I think it's
funny that we're all sitting here
laughing cuz we know they know we know
it just keeps happening but that's why I
like Matt Gates man I mean for whatever
for what whatever it is let's uh let's
let's let's talk about the other guy
here we go everybody you ready for this
one bman Camp slams Nazi Republicans
after fire alarm flap how this is the
state of Congress we're in serious
trouble okay let me just I think you
guys have seen seen the story so this
dude pulls the fire alarm next to
next to a door with a sign that says
depress the uh the you know bar or
whatever for 30 seconds to open the door
this basically causes a stall in the
vote over the the the government
spending Bill he then says later you
know I thought pulling the fire alarm
opened the door which I'm sorry I don't
think he is so stupid he actually
believes that I think he's smart enough
to recognize if he says he intentionally
pulled the fire alarm he gets criminally
charged so it's a I just thought it
opened the door but I got to tell you
ignorance of the law is no excuse for
breaking it he should be criminally
charged so after he gets a bunch of
flack from everybody saying you know
he's trying to stall in delay he then
has his Camp puts out a message saying
that they're all Nazis this is really
really funny let me see I I don't know
if they actually have the messages here
uh what he actually put out but uh he
then comes out here we go Tim cast.com
rep Jamal Bowman condemns use of Nazi in
memo issued to Democrats by his office
saying it is important to specify the
term Nazi to to refer to members of the
Nazi party and neo-nazis and then here's
a tweet from John LaVine rep Jamal
Bowman says Michael nolles is a Nazi
hellbent on keeping only white men alive
and in power we cannot allow him and
others to push their evil agenda blah
blah blah so there you go we can sit
here and sing the Praises of Matt Gates
or uh uh Dr Ron Paul when he was in
office and this is what Democrats have
to offer I suppose for the record
Michael NOS is a Christian uh Republican
not a Nazi he doesn't serve the Nazi
party and I'm pretty sure his wife's
Jewish but all of that side these people
are horrible nothing's going to happen
to Bowman he has Democrat privilege you
can do whatever you want you can pull
fire alarms you can be racist you can
right before we started there was the
ilhan Omar story about giving illegals
IDs it's like they can do anything and
they get more power that's how they
operate and they protect their own much
better than Republicans do uh but this
guy's a buffoon you guys I'm sure you
covered the video of him screaming at
Massie in the hallway a couple months
ago this guy is just he's the worst of
the worst but he's exactly what the
future of the Democrat Party is he
changed his story from uh I I thought it
would open the door when I pulled the
fire alarm to I was in a rush I had to
vote so I pulled the fire alarm he
changed his story very recently he's
saying that the door right the the door
is store the door is normally open he
was in a rush and when he got to the
door and saw that it was closed he
thought I have to get to the capital
building and if I pull the fire alarm
it'll open the door so I can get through
despite the fact that a sign on the door
explaining how to open is it now okay
for congressmen to pull fire alarms when
they're in a rush because that's the
precedent that will set if he doesn't
get arrested well I I I disagree the the
excuse he's making is I thought it
opened the door so it won't set
president but he should be arrested Ian
you should go to the capital right now
and go into that same building in that
same location and you test out your
theory being I I just need to leave here
and then see what happens to you because
you could say you made it made a quinky
dink but that's actually a really
interesting point what if someone goes
in there and says the exact Republican
though no no I'm just mean l literally
anybody I mean you will get arrested you
pull the they're going to arrest you and
they're going to give you all the insane
BS you know disrupting an official
proceeding or whatever the Democrats
really don't like that one and and how
much government resources and time are
are you wasting MTG released a very
interesting video showing how what uh
this Congress member were saying was an
absolute lie but I think uh The Babylon
B definitely Takes the Cake here as they
H uh wrote an article that was titled
Democrats propose a 12 billion doll
study to determine what strange red
handle thingy with fire alarm on it does
and they they really just nailed this
entire situation very well more than any
other news organization out there as of
course there's so many lies by the
Democrats there's Lies by the
Republicans too but all of them are just
full of crap he should be held
responsible for what he did doesn't this
just seem to you like this is the next
step of where the Democrats are
obviously going pulling fire alarms like
you've got John fedman in his hoodie and
they Chang the rules so he can wear
shorts and a hoodie they Chang back
didn't they did they change it back they
did I I was away for a couple days I
might have missed one so they they
actually change it back are pissed off
about that one well that I I'm I'm I
have not heard that I am completely
Amazed by that but he will figure out a
way around it but the just the basic
idea that every Norm that we have
everybody that is that is uh respectful
and decent and competent will eventually
be purged and you will just get a bunch
of people that pull fire alarms and tell
you that they don't know what they're
doing and a lot of people will be like
oh I guess he didn't know what he was
doing you know you know what it is is uh
all that is required of evil to Triumph
is that good men do nothing and too many
people allow people like Bowman to to to
run and win too many people support it
but what if someone like pulled out a
gun while they were shooting a movie and
they were like oops and the gun went off
and and they they killed the
cinematographer like like Alec Baldwin
did you would think like ignorance of
not knowing that the gun was loaded with
the bullet you would think that's not an
excuse to commit the
crime it's kind of a joke because ran
should be criminally charged the problem
is our system is broken and corrupt I I
I don't this is one I'm I'm going to
have a hard time letting go of this one
because for years to come people can
pull fire alarms in Congress at this
this isn't taken care of right away I
hate to tell you they're letting them go
you got you know you know he'll probably
get a ticket they'll be like he got he
got to F his office paid for it which is
your tax dollar something like that will
happen and then we'll be told it's
because America is systemically racist
oh yeah that's the next thing he's gonna
come out and say yeah of course he is
they wouldn't have done this to a black
guy Lauren bobbert would have been
walking off scottf free yep white
supremacy how blackpilled are you um I'm
a little blackpilled about the nation as
a whole but I'm very white pilled on
what's going on here in Florida and I
think that that's the freedom or that's
the future of America we're going to
kind of go our different directions and
it and and it's Flor declares
independence I I think we're probably
not that far from that to some extent in
some way I only mean that's part well
it's not even that you'd have to do that
this the states are set up to be
Laboratories of democracy and yes you
can't solve all the problems in your own
State because yes they can still screw
you they can still screw you at the
border by letting in all these people
but you can control your border to some
degree you control de Independence no
not today no not yet yes yesterday
please declare independence immediately
get away from the union and just leave
us alone please let's put it this way I
never thought I would have been a
separatist in the Star Wars prequels but
the more you watch them and you see
what's going on you kind of go well
actually when an entire system is
corrupt getting out of the system does
make sense I'm not for that well you
know the other problem with that is that
the red States if the red States really
were just like let's kind of all get
together and not not leave like some
drastic way but just kind of do our own
thing have economic trading policies and
all that on our own the blue States will
never let them go Florida and Texas and
South Dakota don't want anything from
the blue States but you California wants
the money and the resources of Florida
they can't keep running these giant
deficits and all of this other
without Florida and the red States
because what's going to increasingly
happen we know this is happening all of
the functional people who build things
who want the government out of the way
who want to produce they're all moving
to the red States and they're leaving
the blue States and don't forget that
Lee zeldon who nobody knew about two
weeks before the New York gubinatorial
election he lost by about 500,000 votes
you know how many people moved out of
New York during Co about 400,000 so it
was that close to flipping what is like
the red The Bluest of blue States and
now it just got further so but this is
this is one of the the big components of
what happens in Florida and Texas why it
flips so red it's people coming here and
then voting red they're voting the right
way I mean I meet the people all the
time because people know that that I did
it very publicly but everyone I meet
here the amount of former Dems that now
tell me their first time Republicans do
you know the numbers on that the the
when Dan santis came into office someone
could check this the uh it I think the
Republicans were actually down by voter
registration and now they're up by like
400,000 or something like that someone
give me the the real numbers on on uh on
our way here in the airport met some
fans and uh they're like oh cool we love
your show and I was like what are you
guys what are you up to and they're like
we're moving to Florida no joke yeah
they're like we're moving and I was like
wow I was like we're on our way to Miami
yeah Miami went red Miami city went red
it's a major urban area urban area is
predominantly overwhelmingly Democrat
can I tell you something so great about
this is just how like functional these
people are I was doing the show one day
and I was talking about the crazy oh it
was right after I was in San Francisco
and I did this video that went viral
just the zombie apocalypse right so I
was talking about San Francisco and la
and Portland Seattle all that and I said
I don't know how many homeless people
there are in my Miami but I know it's
not that many cuz you never see them and
we we take care of business here
literally while I'm doing it my I get a
text from Suarez the mayor of Miami and
he says Dave tell your audience we have
348 and I'm working on it like think
about the functional difference of the
people that are running this state and
this City versus almost the entire
country I think you were looking for
numbers earlier uh Republican party of
Florida numbers for that and 2023 was 50
5.2 million before that it was 5.3
million in 22 so there down 80,000 or
something wait in 2020 it was 5.2 in
2023 it was 5.24 in 2020 I'm going
backwards let me go forward in 2019
there were 4.7 2020 there were 5.2 so
that's 500,000 people joined the
Republican party in that year uh
2021 it went down from 5.2 to 5.1 so a
million registered Republicans left the
party 100,000 you mean no no no oh yeah
100,000 I'm sorry I'm getting these
numbers wrong um it's this is from dos.
florida.com does that sound familiar
these the the net number you're talking
about is basically in four years it's
about 500,000 more Republicans here and
that that is like a massively huge
number for a state that is now really
the reddest state in the nation I mean
the guy won by 20 points has a super
majority in 300,000 less Democrats in
2017 there was 4.5 million registered
Republicans today there are 5.2 million
uh registered Republicans in the State
of Florida how many Democrats there are
4.6 as of today and in wow and in 20177
it was 4.8 this is a major urban urban
State like the the all of Florida is a
developed well we we personally have to
thank the Cubans here they've been
through socialism and and the communism
they they're pretty based they don't
like C centralization and I get along
with them very well cuz I come from
communist Poland we don't like
government there either they don't like
big government here as well but you know
the other thing that happens once you
start doing things right I think one of
the things the santis has done really
well so for example I disagree with the
SST on the six week heartbeat Bill
personally my personal belief is 15
weeks that's kind of where I would even
be on 12 weeks but I'm I'm not as let's
say conservative on that but when you do
strong conservative policies not only do
you get strong conservative people to
move into your state you also scare off
the wack job lefties so somebody that
might have moved to Florida before
because of low taxes suddenly they're
like but wait a minute I like six-month
abortions I'm never going to move there
so it it actually doubly helps you you
get the good people coming and you're
also putting a force field so the
wackadoodles don't don't move in but
there's a a major negative to that and
if you look at what California did with
illegal immigration they end up getting
between one about one or two extra seats
in Congress to vote against your rights
ban your right to keep in bar arms and
things like that by breaking the law by
what by allowing them to vote you mean
they don't allow them to vote whatever
it is they allow them to do when
non-citizens are allowed into the state
of California they are counted in the
census which then abortions
congressional seats so you don't need to
be a citizen in order for your presence
to have an effect on the Electoral
College and Congress I blame this on the
federal government and and also the
Banana Republic of California there's
actually is a a risk here if all of the
people are leaving their areas and I'm
not saying they should stay they should
certainly be moving away from these
cities in my opinion for the most part
but if they all come to Florida and then
Florida wins by 20 points if you're
thinking about strategic allotment of
your resources Jerry mandering comes to
mind you want to make sure that you are
putting just enough people in the right
places to win those districts if you get
half a million people from three or four
states put them all in Florida you're
well Florida's already R you know
Florida doesn't need 500,000 new people
Florida did get more seats because of
that oh for sure for sure it's one extra
seat just about one more state is going
to be given to Florida but you'd be
better off winning outright win or take
all states by putting 100,000 in five
states as opposed to 500,000 in one
state to be clear as a Newan I'm not for
everybody moving here like you know what
I mean like you really do need to spread
it out and as a nation we do have to if
we're going to remain United at all
which gets us back to the other thing
but yeah we need to but look a whole no
if we are too I think maybe we aren't
but yeah I think yes well look how many
people moved to Tennessee in the last
three years I mean it's it's a crazy
amount of people as well but you know it
might just be we talk a lot about
National divorce Civil War what it means
and there are a lot of people that think
this is like where we are now is where
we will be until the fighting starts and
there's there's another reality San
Francisco is in disarray it's falling
apart Los Angeles is falling apart
there's feces everywhere there the
Westfield mall they they was it um they
relinquished the claim to the property
to their lender oh in San Francisco yeah
yeah yeah the mall uh two of the biggest
hotels did this the reality may be that
these blue States stay on this path we
maintain stability for five six seven
years and these cities just lose all
their political power and capital now
right now they can claim oh we make all
the money and blue states do all the
work you're a city okay it's outside of
the cities is all red for the most part
if these cities are mismanaged to this
degree and their policies are going
insane and people are leaving it's
called a brain drain the people who are
leaving are the hard workers who don't
want to be in a place where they're
being oppressed for their hard work so
they go to Florida where they can strive
where they can they can uh Thrive and
then the people who remain are demanding
of the government the government raises
taxes the system falls apart give it 5
10 years New York will be a a pigy pit
stain no one's going to want to be there
anymore and they will have no political
cap capital and then people are going to
look to Florida and they're going to
look to Texas and they're going to look
to Tennessee well the next version is
then between the fenel and God knows
what sex these people are doing and
everything else then the super virus
starts the zombie apocalypse and then
and then yes we do have to put Gators at
the border to keep these freaks out Gat
do you think you could have benefited at
all California if you'd stayed no I did
everything I could do I fought as hard
as anyone I campaigned with Larry Elder
I got audited by the state three days
after the campaign ended that was the
day I put my house for sale for real
um California wants to go in that
direction there are good people there I
was just there I had dinner with some
friends like there are still a good
people remaining but everyone's
depressed it's all they talk about uh
yes you're going to find pockets of
Sanity of course it's not all that crazy
everywhere but you're right the brain
drain it's not just what it does to uh
the businesses and everything else it's
what it does to the human Spirit when
you realize you're in a why would you
ever open a store a freaking sneaker
store or a pizza joint if you know on
any given moment they're going to burn
it down what your family so what happens
is the brain drain is the people who
normally start the businesses leave cuz
they can't and the people who don't
start businesses stay and demand of the
government this is the same exact thing
that happened in in Cuba Cuba faced a
major brain drain and this is why a lot
of people speculate that we had a total
almost collapse of their society because
everyone was leaving Cuba leaving
communism leaving somewhere where the
government was oppressing them taxing
them controlling them and they left for
places like like Florida and and this is
why Cuba is the state that it is now
this is why the Soviet Union fell this
is why communism never works and the
people in that country usually go hungry
because the people capable are the ones
usually punished by that entire system
you want to go you want to go while
you're in Miami to a place where
everyone's going to know you and buy you
a Mojito go to Little Havana down here
and hang out with some of the Cubans who
will talk about Freedom until 4 in the
morning hopped up on sugar and rum these
are good people who care they care about
freedom and you said Mojitos yeah no
mint for me you mentioned ciche we'll
have a we'll we don't drink no booze
here we'll have a little Kucha with them
but but kuch that little cucha yeah yeah
yeah but but no the Cubans here are are
very based and they're they're very very
very strongly independent they don't
like government they don't like
centralization and I think this is why
Florida is so great because of them I I
keep thinking about pills you mentioned
earlier like the brain drain and it's
all kind of circling around my head now
like just distractions in general people
playing video games was watching porn
Tak an opiates or whatever opioids what
do you what is your vision for how to
help people I mean actually I I just say
uh weed apparently can help people with
withdrawals you know it can help
suppress some of the pain that felt by
opiate withdrawals CBD CBD so but there
there are paths to maybe introduce new
new new things but like what do you see
because I think this is like no matter
how political you get it always comes
down to if the population's doped up
population ain't going anywhere well
look I'm not Jordan Peterson so I'm not
in the business of giving life advice to
people but you know I do my August Off
the Grid thing for one month a year for
seven years I freaking put this thing in
a safe and I have no news no TV no
social media nothing I know absolutely
nothing couple years we've gone to Bora
Bora a couple years this year we were in
the Mexican rainforest wow and just
disappear this year actually this year I
really now having kids this year I
didn't want to do I didn't read any
books I just did nothing I I I mean we
exercised ate good food but that was it
and then I come back and I have fresh
eyes on this you know Tim since me and
you were we're like OG in this freaking
thing right like like think about it
where we started and and where both of
us are respectivly we've been doing this
for a long time was later lot of people
it's yeah but roughly like we're
oldtimers now in this game I hate to
tell you man but when when I first met
you you had freaking nothing and you've
built something amazing like we've been
in this for a long time and how many
people do you know that we're in the
similar world as us that have lost their
freaking mind gone crazy just every the
whole thing breaks them the politics
breaks them the money breaks them the
fame breaks them or with a lack of money
or lack of Fame blah blah blah and and
to me one month so I take one 12th of
the year without this freaking thing and
I come back and I'm fresh and I'm ready
to go and and I think it's kept you know
kept me in the game you're asking people
to basically uh you we we'll do a Marvel
reference so that everybody everybody
can can understand and enjoy yeah in an
Infinity War when Thor is standing in
the way of the of the the star uh the
star Forge you're asking people in this
in politics to stand in the center of a
forge being burned on all sides not
everybody can handle that oh that's
where he gets the big hammer or
something right he gets he has to and it
blasts him and he's like and he's like
dying yeah this is all right I'm asking
people to do that is that such a big
deal this this job is being inside of a
pre pressure cooker yeah 24/7
Non-Stop and some people like popcorn
yeah when's the last time you did one
day one day uh no usually uh I would
say like like Saturdays yeah so you do
try to I would say Saturdays I'm like
99% reduced all right you know like I I
still check my phone for texts and stuff
like that but uh usually Saturday
morning on and then around Sunday night
I'm back on and I'm picking everything
Twitter hell hole yesterday man there's
nothing like it oh it'll get you it'll
it'll bring you to hell and then you're
just lucky if you can get back in but
I'll tell you you do this if you can try
to do it even for a weekend or a week or
whatever like when I'm 3 weeks into this
thing I'm remembering friends that I not
thought of second graders I can
basically remember every kid in my class
I'll have whole songs albums in my brain
I can tell you every word like there is
so so much stuff in the recesses of the
human mind that we just we just
completely uh on with day-to-day
holy this person who I don't know I
never heard of they said something and
I'm going to destroy them for it and
we're doing that all day long and there
is there is Magic in us in our in our
mind your dopamine receptors your
dopamine receptors are just being
blasted and it's pretty much just just
un unhooking from The Matrix I used to
do it every every two weeks but things
have been so crazy it's been it's been
difficult within the last few years to
take a break but you reminded me I need
to take a break that's it's just like
meditation if you can't meditate for 10
minutes you got to meditate for 20
minutes exactly exactly the machine
ain't going to slow down I hate to tell
you this is why vacation is important
yeah let's uh let's jump to this tweet
here let's get on Twitter we're gonna
get on to it let's get to murder we're
going to we have this tweet from Scott
Adams this story as Dave says is wild
Scott Adams tweeted July 1st 2020 if
Biden is elected there's a good chance
he will be dead within the year
Republicans will be hunted police will
stand down on September 30th Josh
Krueger says the Dilbert dude is like
Nostradamus look at this prediction from
2020 wow Eerie making fun of Scott Adams
for uh having made that point and then
we have this story from Tim cast.com
journalist shot seven times in
Philadelphia home Josh Krueger was
killed in his home on Monday y That's
crazy so this is actually what this is
uh this was he was killed today is that
it I thought it was uh 1:00 a.m. jeez
wow so this guy who uh was just mocking
Scott Adams over his prediction about
this stuff was shot and killed in his
own home I think the news is that there
was no sign of a breaking he had mocked
and argue with critics expressing
concern of a rising crime in
Philadelphia yeah he he made fun of
people who um weren't taking Co
seriously and he said Co is more of a
serious threat than the urban violence
that's happening all throughout the
United States and he was pretty much
ridiculing a lot of people who are
taking it seriously as I think if you
live in a major city you should be
taking um you know surviv and uh and
personal protection very seriously I
think you might want to consider not
being there but let's uh here's one he
says look it's that Lawless land of
liberals in Philly where shootings are
dropping to levels not seen in years
here's another one bro speak for your
block not mine it isn't ruined the city
isn't ruined and just because Larry ker
keeps winning in landslides doesn't mean
Philly is a heap of cinders and Ash no
matter how much people say like the rest
of this country we are dealing with
uptic and crime the crazy thing is yo I
saw these tweets when when he when I I
don't I don't know when he posted this
one but I remember seeing people
retweeting this before he died yeah it's
not too long ago I think they were in
August or yeah right I remember when
these tweets were going on people were
saying like are you crazy and like
you're not considering what the people
need this dude was killed in his own
home in Baltimore we had the story of
that Tech CEO who was found beaten to
death on her roof by a guy who only a
few days earlier had tortured a couple
he broke broke into their house tied
them up raped the woman set them both on
fire police knew he did it and they said
nothing and then he killed again and
then they came and said okay okay this
is getting serious these are the things
that are happening in our cities don't
get me wrong these things happen crime
happens all this stuff happens but it is
just I don't know what you'd call it
shocking coincidence or whatever that
this guy has been defending the
positions that Democrats have taken that
have led to this increase in crime he
has mocked people who feared that you
would be seriously harmed by police
standing down and he lost his life dude
do you know how many people I knew at
the height of coid and the summer of
love when everybody was rampaging
through everything and there ransacking
all the streets and all of that how
many Hollywood liberals that I knew that
were all day long for the previous five
years ranting and raving about gun
rights who were calling me and other
people that I knew on where where can we
buy guns
I I have a friend who would never want
me to be named but like a big time
celebrity person uh who I knew you know
could get guns right and everybody was
trying to almost it doesn't even matter
the gender of this person but uh they
were they were inundated with the amount
of people because when push comes to
shove you know basic you know it's uh a
conservative is just a liberal mug by
reality I think this guy actually had a
gun is that possible in Philly or is it
yeah no he said in another Twitter
thread that he had a a gun and a guy had
previously broken into his house and he
didn't get the gun he figured out
another way of escalating it even though
the guy was standing in his bedroom or
something yeah this is where the story
gets a little deeper like on face Valley
you're like uhoh random violence maybe
but in reality this guy has had a
history with drugs um drug abuse and he
like what they you were just saying he
at some point in April of this year or
some other year had woke up and a guy
was in his room and he's like what are
you doing here some guy he used to know
how didd he get in I must have given him
a key maybe he didn't even remember
giving a guy a key to his house so this
is the guy who at 1:30 in the morning
with no sign of a break-in gets shot in
his own apartment like who are those
people how did they get in if there's no
Breakin and I don't know that the no
Breakin is definitely confirmed did you
confirm that or not I haven't I don't I
just didn't see any signs of a break in
no one mentioned any kind of breaking
and entering so 1:30 in the morning guy
shot seven times in his own room has a
history of giving his key out to people
and not remembering it and history
that's just an excuse because it
happened and he didn't want to come out
and be like yeah but conservatives I got
to tell you when David hog said when
they were getting The Mask mandates and
he says yeah but I I don't I don't want
to take it off because people think I'm
a republican yeah like these are the
people who would rather allow someone to
break into their home and kill them then
admit conservatives were right he
actually tweeted that he was ready to
die or some something like I guess I'll
die then or something something like
that who David hog uh no Josh Krueger
guy I don't know I I glanced at it
earlier didn't save the location of the
Tweet but if you scroll down his feed
maybe it's there it's tough to talk
about cuz the guy did just die so we got
to be be a little sensitive about the L
that's the thing you know uh so Mike
cernovich had some tweets out recently
about how if uh Biden wins he says have
you had to talk something about have you
had to talk with your family about how
you be framed for a crime so they can
kill you or whatever and I'm like a bit
aggressive a bit aggressive I I don't
completely I should say I don't disagree
with with with Mike just a bit
aggressive and my response was people
don't know don't understand what happens
to a country when they begin arresting
their political opposition and
lawyers so I think there's a normaly
bias people don't want to believe
believe it and that's why I like to do
the time travel test go back insert x
amount of years and tell people
everything that happened today they
won't believe you you go back six years
and say Donald Trump will be indicted
they they'll go after his lawyers
they'll indict his lawyers they'll start
issuing fines and the 200 Grand on
lawyers who argued on his behalf in the
election people are going to be like
shut up that'll never happen in this
country mention January 6 to someone six
seven years ago and they're going to be
like oh shut up that won't happen that's
crazy yeah there's a a viral the viral
video of the mayor of Chicago in 72 oh
yeah we played it on my show he was
saying that looters you shoot looters to
kill them and or arsonists you shoot
them to kill looters you shoot to Mame
and this is just the governor or the
governor of he was he was the mayor of
Chicago think about how that city has
fallen no it was uh someone can grab his
name I think he was the mayor in about
72 you guys remember we we'll get it
yeah um but it's a great video it's like
you're watching a competent executive be
like I'll defend the Free People of my
city the people who are doing it right
instead of defending the looters and the
arsonists and everyone else and also
saying in essence since we we believe we
live in a society to quot George
castanza like we either live in a
society or we don't but this is why I am
optimistic look man yeah it was M daily
1968 W because I'm pretty sure because
the da run ran Chicago forever but uh uh
look man when they're aborting their
kids when they're sterilizing their kids
when they would rather there'll be none
of them left they won't exactly they
won't defend themselves they won't
advocate for the defense and they will
advocate for the machine that hates them
I'm just like if you got a guy who says
no guns no guns oh someone broke in my
house don't worry I still don't need
guns it's like well this dude is not
likely to have kids and I'm not you got
to zoom out it's never it's it's not
about what one person does or doesn't do
it's about what most people do and even
to tiny tiny degrees if
50.01% of liberals engage in behaviors
that result in them having no kids
they're they're going to slowly cease to
exist and they're ideology will go along
with them I hope but communism's been
around for a long time yeah and also if
you factor in like you know China using
Tik Tok to brainwash a generation of
Americans it's not as simple as just
pure like like numbers in terms of who's
giving birth it's there's a there is an
ideological war being waged on children
that are that are converting right I I I
agree but I do think it's I I still
think having kids is 10 to 100 times
more impactful than social manipulation
social manipulation plays a large role
but there's Inver social reaction right
so uh uh Libertarians conservatives
post- liberals coming out and saying no
to the stuff in school no to Tik Tok get
your kids off social media homeschool
your kids that counterforce to a certain
degree will negate the effect of China
or whatever social manipulation we're
experiencing you add to that mix they're
literally advocating for things that put
their lives in danger or inhibit them
from having
children I think in 20 years you got a
two to one Republican advantage I hope
you're right man I I I how often do you
do out white pills these days that I've
been saying this thing for a couple
years and people argue that I'm wrong
and I'm like because they make the point
you made and I'm like I agree they're
trying to indoctrinate kids but when you
look at what Florida did with with the
books saying like when when Des santis
did that press conference where he's
like look at these books look at what
was in these books Nikki freed said Ron
Des STIs posting butt plug porn it's
like he's criticizing you uh that right
there as a governor exposing this and
giving them no recourse because all she
could do is admit it that's waking
people
up like yes there are a lot of
conservatives it's funny when they come
to timcast iroll Studios and they're
like they say oh my kids going to
college next I'm like which one and
they're like oh NYU and I'm like are you
insane like do you watch the show you're
about to be on maybe University of
Chicago that's pretty much it that's
pretty much it couple others did you
talk publicly about how you guys want to
raise the kids in terms of schooling
yeah stuff like that you know it's funny
I not really but I would say just sort
of generally speaking I mean first off
we're in Florida where we have really
some of the best public schools in the
United States and it's ironic because
you know 20 years ago when Florida was
thought of as The Golden Girls and this
is where everyone goes to retire and
there's no income tax there were bad
schools here because older people didn't
want to put money towards it and there
just wasn't an income tax in the first
place now we have basically the best
schools in the nation I don't my I mean
just because of my uh public nature I
don't think we'll send them to public
school but but regardless the idea that
you just hand hand your kid off to some
state employee and that they could call
your son by the opposite gender name
they can make up a name and then hide it
from you and the whole machine
was like DeSantis is the bad guy for
fighting this is so bananas here here's
here's what's crazy is that these
children are reportedly experiencing
suicidal ideation and the the state says
withhold that from the parents yeah if
the purpose of transition is to reduce
suicidal ideation why would you withhold
that information from the parents it's a
it's a lie it is a lie what do you think
about like giving kids access to the uh
Tik Tok the internet how are you looking
at that well I thought VC's answer at
the debate did you see that was was
pretty poor actually so they asked him
in the debate uh because he got on he
had been talking about banning Tik Tok
for about a year and then apparently he
hung out with Jake Paul and Jake Paul
convinced him to get on Tik Tok so V
said well I want to get young voters and
the Republican Party always loses so we
have to get where they are but then when
I'm in office I'll ban it and no one
under 16 should be on social media it's
like well first off who gives the
president of the United States the right
to say who can be on social media and
what age you can be that's a really
Bizarro um authoritarian tendency that
he said right there but that's sort of
the ends justify the means kind of thing
like do you want to use Chinese spyware
and encourage people to be on Chinese
spyware so that the day you get the
power you can ban the Chinese spyware uh
so no I do not I personally don't have
Tik Tok I did not want to use it on my
show at all my man Brock over here uh my
social media guy he wanted us to be on
there I said you are I am not pressuring
you at all I said if you want a a burner
phone to put it on and blah you go ahead
and he did that but but I yeah I want
nothing to do with the got it backwards
you don't ban kids from social media
although I think kids shouldn't be on
social media but that should be up to
the parent obviously but it should it
should be that we criminally charge
people who post say like porn on Twitter
so if you were a person who was on
Twitter and you post pornographic
material then it should be Elon Musk and
it should be the person who posts who
are criminally charged for posting
you're talking about illegal porn or
porn but wait you're saying that's how
it should be right now I mean so you
want Elon Musk to be held account for
some for for legal porn that's on the
platform yes I do so let's let's put
this way so you have a disagreement of
just policy with him because he said
it's fine right so imagine uh you own a
bookstore and that's all it is it's a
bookstore but you know that a lot of the
books in the store are graphic hardcore
pornography and you allow children in
guess what's going to happen
yeah if you if you have an adult
bookstore and you allow children in the
police are going to come and you are
going to get in serious trouble so you
want some basic parental rules around
Twitter I I actually don't know what I
have no idea I'm singling out Twitter
kind of as is the shock value to say
Elon Musk right but the reality is my
question and we we talked about this
quite a bit how did we get to the point
in society where we've decided that we
have the internet which is effectively
public streets and you know what you
might ask your 10-year-old to go run to
the store and pick up a thing of some
milk right right it's no big deal but
then there's someone standing in the
street corner and they're waving around
a big picture of adults in hardcore
adult activities the kids sees it freaks
out anybody who sees it they call the
police guess what the police are going
to do they're going to arrest that guy
and they're going to say you violated a
whole bunch of public looted lude and
and and luding lascivious laws indecent
exposure Etc but the internet which
functions essentially a similar in a
similar way it's a public space where
people can post things there's no
repercussions for any of these
businesses to allow minor children at
the age of 13 and even younger to access
things that would otherwise be illegal
to distribute so if Twitter had the same
regulations related to age that I guess
PornHub has or something where you have
to click something you'd be okay with
that meaning you yeah okay but you
you're saying as long as there's some
system in place where I just don't know
what the deal I have I have no
recollection when I signed on to Twitter
do you have to say your yeah you want to
go to an adult bookstore you walk in and
say ID please you show them your ID and
say okay now you're old enough to be in
here right that's because we don't want
kids going into adult bookstores Twitter
should be the same
if you if you post lwd and lascivious
adult activities should put a blur over
the image and then only people who have
verified IDs can view these these
controlled images right it's interesting
because Elon has a different policy on
this than you can't do that on Facebook
right I haven't been on Facebook in
years I have no freaking clue but I'm
sure you can right yeah I'm pretty sure
uh you could but it's extremely
borderline so when you're on Facebook
and Instagram it's it's you know uh
women W wet t-shirts on and you could
pretty much see everything but therefore
it is not her being naked it's still
somehow allowed shown to a lot of people
put porn on Instagram but you can but
not explicit so there's there's there's
a lot of tricks they do to get around it
one of the tricks they do is they're uh
when on Instagram you know to do the
Mosaic where you upload a bunch of
pictures and then it it makes your feed
it creates the oh yeah yeah yeah oh oh
so each individual photo is not but Al
together they right they got the tricks
they got the tricks but my my point is
simple I am not literally saying I
believe in the moral absolute position
that you know we must do these things I
am saying if it is the standard right
now to say kids can't drink kids can't
look at porn you need an ID to enter
this establishment why don't we have
those same restrictions how did the
internet come to be that we just assume
as a society it should not have these
safeguards for children probably because
it a lot of it was built by 16-year-olds
like sitting in their room I think it
was because it was never taken seriously
because in the early days of the
internet they were just like it was the
Wild West nobody knew what the hell was
nobody used it we're now at the point of
ubiquity the internet is everything and
we've not stopped to ask ourselves are
we okay with creating public highways
and public streets where children can
get access to graphic murder snuff and
hardcore point to be honest I'm I'm okay
with the highways being there we just
need to police them properly because if
you go after the network for something
that happens on the network you'll end
up crashing the whole system but this is
my point the person who posts it but the
solution there is I don't think we
should ban porn I think the way Twitter
and every platform should work is if you
post it it is blurred and you can't see
it unless you have verified your your
your age it would be an interesting
conversation YouTube sort of does this
but they don't have any real like
YouTube will age restrict certain
content but all you have to do is log in
and claim you're a certain age you don't
need an idea no no or or you could you
know shove things up you know what and
still be on YouTube and that's totally
fine but if you question yeah yeah there
was a particular video that we can't
even much describe that's allowed and
you
approval YouTube had videos with
millions of hits called what's in my bum
where they would show people and then
they'd have to guess what was and I'm
like this is not not just items but
other individuals pornography has
individuals yeah yeah but I mean
pornography has been weapon there were
other people up there yes yes yes what
are you saying still there like a
what are you talking about don't get any
ideas here ribbon uh calm your calm your
horses there okay sir the uh another
human being was inside of another I
can't family friendly show we we'll save
it for the family familyfriendly show
here please for thisit but um
pornography has been weaponized
militaries have used it against
populations how do you handle that
without destroying free speech I think
is is is something that I think is is
worth looking into but I think we should
always try to prioritize uh freedom of
speech without violating and destroying
and running a fifth generational Warfare
program on the future of this country as
of course it's not just Tik Tok it's not
just Instagram it's Hollywood it's
Corporate America it's Black Rock it's
the ESG score it's the banks that are
all working in tandem destroying the
children of this country and you know I
I I want to agree with you Tim but I
think uh when it comes to your kind of
white pill moment here it could it could
go either way because if we look at the
kids of kellyan Conway you look at her
do daughter you look at Elon Musk he has
a non-binary child how how in the world
did that happen you can lose your kids
the machine you could also lose your
your kids to the state with CPS being
overly aggressive and and going after
parents and and also abusing and hurting
children and other unspeakable ways so I
think the fight is there how do you
handle it without giving the government
more authority over you I think is the
question that I want answer well I think
Tim without belaboring the point I don't
think you really want to go into to all
of the companies and force them to do
all sorts of things but it sounds like
to me you want at least the internet
service providers to have a little more
uh control over things right because
Elon is running a private company so to
me he can do what my personal belief is
he can do what he wants with it I
disagree and yeah you don't think he can
do what he wants with it no I think no
he if he's okay go ahead go ahead I I I
don't want to put words in your mouth
you can't sell boo 13-year-olds at a bar
no no no we have within the confines of
the law right right I think as long as
he's within the confines of the law and
that's where we're getting I guess he's
not well then it is illegal to run a
business that delivers pornographic
materials to Children Elon Musk is doing
that
I I guess under the way you're saying it
it's not under the way I'm saying it's
like no I just don't no I'll take your
word for I just don't know exactly what
the sign up process is on all that stuff
but so I believe what you're saying yeah
I think because you need a bank account
I signed on it 12 years ago I have no
idea any internet access you need to
have a bank account you can't a kid
can't get internet access that's not
true no I don't well you're talking
about Twitter itself just a service that
is quote unquote free you you can't like
the fact that these platforms exist in
outright say you have to be at least 13
13 years old to use it means okay fine
your parents can drive a kid a kid can't
get to the adult bookstore because it's
it's 10 mil away so his parents drive
him there but and they say yeah they
drop him off around the corner they
don't know what he's doing and then he
goes goes adult bookstore and there
there is Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk
being like hey you're 13 you're good to
look at all this stuff don't worry about
it I don't understand how that how how
that is you got to have sensitive
filters but it's hard to make sure that
they always work and like to destroy the
network because one of them got through
is a risky problem is is the argument
that we've come to a point in society
where we've decided that porn should be
available to Children is that is that is
that the argument no that's not my
argument no no I mean my point is like
no one no one will disagree it is a fact
if you go to an adult adult bookstore
they say you need an ID to come in
otherwise we'll be breaking the law yeah
the internet quite literally has porn
websites they and and kids can go to
them without any restrictions and when
when uh laws were proposed to require
IDs for porn websites these porn
websites said no they were like how dare
you because you know a lot of lot of
these companies that that run ads I bet
a lot of these kids a lot of their views
come from children the joke I made on
Twitter is when you're on the internet
no one knows you're 14 because a lot of
these politicians like you you'll see
you you'll see you know insert
politician arguing with someone I'm like
you're 40 and that person you're
responding to is probably 14 but how
many of these businesses get their money
off of viewership not direct pay and
like they're running weird ads or
whatever and those kids generate ads so
my point is simply this either we agree
that we have never allowed children to
go to adult bookstores and we must
maintain that same standard in all areas
of the public which means Twitter must
immediately restrict this stuff or we
agree that you know what we've evolved
as a society we now think children
should have access to adult material
what do you think about erotic text you
ever there's like erotic novels then we
also have to hold Facebook accountable
because a lot of children use Facebook
and they send explicit photos of each
other over that platform as well so if
we're going to go after this we we have
to go after Mark Zuckerberg as well if
we're going to be implementing those
laws as well so um another aspect to
really kind of carefully uh unravel all
of this is also just what happened with
Twitter a couple months ago after Elon
Musk took it over he came out and we
found out through the Twitter files that
there was even a scenario a situation
where a child was uh hurt in in very
unspeakable ways that we can't mention
here on this particular broadcast and
that incident was broadcasted on Twitter
Twitter knew for about 2 weeks that this
person was a child was hurt and and the
videos of them being hurt in adult ways
was being shared on their platform
Twitter decided not to do anything about
it not even intervene the victim was
demanding the remov demanding that that
their private photos and videos of them
being hurt uh be taken down Twitter said
no we're not going to do that you know
one thing I can say uh in sort of elon's
Defense related to all to that sort of
thing not to your sort of philosophical
point is that when he got there and
having met him a couple times now and
talked about this stuff he there are so
many bad people still at that company
and he's working to get rid of them and
that there were systems in place to do
all of the awful things Twitter was
basically remember when Jack dorsy
tweeted that that we don't Shadow ban I
mean he actually testified underrot they
don't Shadow ban I went to Twitter and I
sat with programmers with like 10
computers in front of me showing me the
entire system where the entire thing was
designed to Shadow ban it wasn't that
they didn't Shadow ban every every
keyword that they used to Shadow ban
every phrase I was on like 20 I should
have asked them about your account maybe
I can try they they they had crazy lists
of all sorts of people if you were
suspended once you could be shadowbanned
in a certain way if you said this word
you could be shadowbanned another way so
there was already such a crazy system in
there that my I would say in elon's
defense you have to give him a little
chance to to fix some of this stuff so
like the child porn thing it's like
people knew there was child porn on
there and nobody cared then Elon took
over and what happened the next day the
Twitter has a major child porn problem
and I forget who it was maybe it was
cernovich somebody tweeted you know it's
interesting all these articles are
popping up about child porn on Twitter
nobody none of the authors who wrote
These articles as in mainstream pieces
had ever written about it before Elon
right so the point is there's a system
in place he was the guy's trying to
fight it I would give him little Grace
on some of no no I my point is not
literally that we should storm into to
Twitter officer right now my point is
the hypocrisy of saying like the
conservative values of don't let kids go
to adult bookstores and bars yeah but
then ignoring the issue of the internet
I guess the best thing you can do as a
parent and it's probably the challenge
for every parent is do you in a time
when your kid is going to be walking
around with this freaking thing don't
give him one right so that's the
challenge and then you want to be the
the one parent that doesn't let the kid
have it and all that no no I get it
it's easy it's easy to say and maybe one
day if you're a parent you'll have to
that challenge put in front of you and I
will and all of us will maybe you know
like that's the thing it's easy to say
it but then people people to it you my
my attitude is uh we see these videos
that went viral where the trans high
school student or middle school student
is beating the girls up oh yeah I think
had a good point where he said if you
homeschool your kids they'll be you know
socially maladjusted right making the
point that they say don't homeschool
your kids because then they won't
understand social behaviors and
everything and it's like if you look at
modern public schooling and how kids are
behaving you don't want your kids
emulating that there's a viral video
showing children during World War II who
are like 9 years old and they sounded
like they were 50 it's like a little kid
and he's like well I quite think it's
interesting Hitler's move in the you
know and it's like it's a child it's
because these kids were raised by adults
yeah kids today are raised by kids and
they're drugged they're raised by the
most important point though is that kids
today are raised by other kids so the
way the way I way I described it is I
had three roommates once that were all
from Europe France Italy and Spain and
they all spoke English as a second
language and they all hung out with each
other as these like exchange students so
when they spoke with each other in
English they made their own colloquial
English because it was a second language
to them when they tried talking to you
you'd be like what like what is that you
just said right they could make up words
they they get something wrong they think
bird is Bor and he says Bor you know the
board in the sky and then the other guy
who's French is like oh bored then they
start talking to you about boards that
they're all over the place they're
eating and pooping and you're like
what's a board what are you talking
about they made a mistake reinforce it
amongst each other kids do this all the
time you put your kid in a Grade School
the kids don't care about the teachers
the kids aren't learning from the
teachers the teachers are not giving
kids behaviors to emulate the kids are
saying the teachers are saying read p
seven start and then the kids go and
socialize with other kids when they
should be socializing with older people
who are working this is this is one of
the biggest problems we have right now
conservative should should consider that
and I think that's why homeschooling is
so important homeschooling Charter
Schools break you know blow up the
Department of Education get rid of virt
you know you could probably get
eliminate a quarter of our public
schools and put that money elsewhere you
could fund students not uh systems all
all of the stuff it's a Rockefeller
education system that's really an
indoctrination system that all needs to
go in my opinion but but we do live in a
very strange world where children can't
get tattoos they can't buy pay-per-view
but they could chop off their
reproductive organs and they could watch
online content that that really doesn't
make sense and we do see uh online
content weaponized it is destroying
children it is destroying families it is
destroying relationships it is having a
severe effect where people are not
having enough children we're having a
huge population crash that does deserve
to be addressed very seriously we should
protect the children but at the same
time I do not want a digital
identification government edal system
watching and telling me what I can and
cannot do so I think there's a fine line
between the two I think personal
responsibility homeschooling children
raising your children without a cell
phone and teaching them that there is a
lot of very bad people out there that
prey on their weaknesses that
psychologically lie to them and abuse
them and hurt them in many ways where
it's it's done subconsciously I I I I
think is something that's going to be
very tough but something that's needed
more than ever and as a parent you are
responsible for your child and no one
else is look you can be lazy
and you can be a not great parent in a
time when the system basically works but
in a time when the system doesn't work
and that's obviously you know where
we're at at a at a certainly at a
national level you just don't have that
luxury anymore and you have to get
involved one way or another do you think
you'll attempt to prevent the kids from
getting cell phones try to push it as
like it's I agree with Tim and spirit on
that like the the answer would be no I'm
going to keep them off this forever but
like you know you you're going to figure
it I can tell you now like we basically
we there there only one I got two kids
who are one we don't have any TV on ever
but every now and again if we need a
freaking break for 5 minutes we put on
Miss Rael on YouTube and she's she's
doing better numbers Than timcast This
Woman's killing it okay now she's like
the one that they say you could have
them watch and she's not breaking their
be careful for the auto no so the auto
what might auto play next sometimes I
find you know an ad will kick in in the
middle and it's an ad about like a
shooting somewhere or something like
it's there's all sorts of weird things
related to that now I don't have YouTube
kids I don't think so so I'm doing it on
the regular YouTube or whatever but the
point is all of that it's it's all easy
to say and the best you can do is is the
best you can do right but Dave you don't
got to worry about cell phones right by
the time
by exactly they're going to be neuralink
man they're going to be like but Dad you
know John schools got the nural link I
want the neural link to play video games
print something out of their ass are you
going to get the neural link yeah enough
enough just like a little bit of quiet
you know do you think you'd get it I no
I mean again it's one of those things
it's like we can all say no to all these
things we can all say boy you know the
Matrix was a warning and I don't want to
be in Ready Player one but then it all
comes and then a huge swath of people do
it and then it becomes ubiquitous and
everyone starts doing it and then yes
some people will kind of not do it um
you'll have no choice I'm thinking if
your kid does or they'll Force you on
because if you're not in the system they
will view you as a terrorist basically
it's not that it's not that extreme it's
going to be you're going to go to the uh
you're going to go to the new Taco Bell
kiosk and they're going to say oh we got
rid of touch interface it's on neural
interface now and they'll be like well
nobody uses touch interface anymore you
like so how do I use the the ask well do
you have a neural link like no that's
all we do have you seen the hand thing
at Whole Foods they they have it already
I saw for the first time we were flying
out here in the airport at DCA they have
they had an Amazon store and it was walk
in and take whatever you want and you
walk up you scan your hand walk in take
whatever you want you walk out and I was
like no thanks apartment buildings have
that right now where if you want to get
to your floor you have to give them a
pal per and then
you to I mean this is like Minority
Report where will SMI Will Smith um Tom
Cruz thank you Tom Cruz has to take the
guy's eye to get through the like that's
where this will all lead we're going to
be chopping off people's hands so you
could buy a uh what do they sell
it Taco Bell now
chimmy crunch been a this is exactly
whych with what you're saying Luke that
I don't like the the the the security
State overlooking and banning porn and
restricting this because if someone gets
a hold of that apparatus it's like you
know what showing elbows is pornography
ban them all like that could happen if
that infrastructure gets built the
individual needs to decide what is right
for them and and clearly there is a war
against them that is destroying them in
many different ways how do you have that
fine balance I I I think we have to
preach personal responsibility but we
also have to live it ourselves so good
luck raising children uh it's not going
to be easy a lot of people are having a
lot of problems so best of luck to you
as of course we are already mind
controlled we are going to go to super
we're going to go to super chats and uh
take your questions so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show and head over to
timcast.net kicking off in about 25
minutes and we've got some good spicy
stuff to talk about Tim can I do a
10-second fact check cuz I got the
numbers that we were talking about
before when the day Dan santis became
Governor Democrats had 300,000 more
registered voters in Florida Republicans
now have 500,000 so it's an 800,000
swing do you know how many of those were
people that switched parties versus how
many people immigrated and immigrated
it's a great question I don't know uh I
would say we know nationally it is a
large number switches yeah and we just
said the Dallas mayor I think it was
Dallas right right oh the Dallas mayor
yeah it was Dallas it was Dallas that's
just switched from Democrat to
Republican all right let's grab some
super chats we got culture abduction
says first and any update oh first
congratulations you are the first Super
Chat any updates on the timcast app for
Apple no I'm looking to see if anybody
in here who knows looking at the
dog you seeing as everybody anyone from
the crew is here they are not here uh
it's in review apple is really hard to
get yeah so all right what else do we
have draxis Storm Shadow says every
ballot should have a tear off tab with
serial number on it you should be able
to take your serial number home and
check a website to verify your vote was
recorded properly or a receipt right
don't don't they don't do that other
places do receipts it's a state issue
though so I I I certainly agree Raymond
g Stanley Jr says Tim imagine being so
dumb you think a fire alarm is a door
handle Dems have gotten so used to lying
It comes naturally these days also why
do they care even about January 6 it was
just a prank
bro I I I do love that idea that
Bowman it's it's no come on no one
really believes that he thought it
opened the door you never know I mean
the IQs have been dropping in un don't
put anything over the stupidity of the
American people I suppose hanlin's Razer
right never tribut to malice which could
be explained by stupidity there's
definitely some malice inol right did he
you know the question is was he trying
to shut down the vote or delay
it either way he should go to he should
get he should get a criminal charge for
pulling a fire alarm right something at
least an acknowledgement moot point fire
alarm does this open the door
yeah I don't think a judge would buy it
I think a judge would be like nice
imagine a dude commits a crime imagine a
guy a kid in school go the open the door
you're honor he's like nice try right
bangs the
gavl all
right fix bayonet says Matt Gates should
draft a bill is a joke that fully funds
Ukraine if the Democrats drop all
prosecu of Donald Trump get Peter zahan
on to talk about graphine and hydrogen
fuel cells oh I like that guy I didn't
know he knew about that stuff let's do
it all
right what is this amang says whatever
happened to free Tibet yeah I have no
idea I saw them everywhere what's going
on in they're they're not existing I
know there's been Chinese oppression at
least heard it's actually just
completely falling off the map nobody
cares anymore I have no idea oh I've
been very busy at work yeah see we just
out of side out of mind inflation I
don't know what to say Jeffrey kovar
says did you guys see the US debt Clock
Matthew 2112 was posted dead center on
the website earlier Jesus is Lord God
bless timcast and crew is that a big
deal wait what us debtclock uh dot it's
us
deathclock.com
yeah somebody it looks like they've
taken it down oh well just search the
news don't search the actual website
yeah I've see I saw a picture of it I'll
look for it but I mean if people report
on it I
guess here we go Shane H Wilder says
there are too many things slipped into
omnius bills mnsb 2995 had a provision
in the 99 page Omnibus that legalized
abortion up to birth negated life-saving
care for born alive infants and ended
informed consent what what was that was
that the recent one
CU how would that like how does that get
through that that was what I was saying
they should have just like when the
omnius is being made be like oh yeah you
know just slide in one sheet of paper
that says like Donald Trump is President
right because nobody reads that
anyway the simplest way if they any of
them wanted to fix anything and this is
this clearly would never happen you want
to solve something the Republicans and
you want to get votes from a certain
amount of people how about we cut taxes
25% on everybody and we cut the entire
federal budget 25% on everybody and we
cut we cut foreign aid like literally
25% across the board and I'm sorry some
post office workers I guess are going to
have to go home and some other people
but how about we just let people have
more of their money isn't that the one
that they never do the one that's the
most obvious one how about you just stop
spending money that you don't have just
stop taking so much money from people
and then we'll figure it out but that's
the one that they can't quite get Let's
uh let's see what we
got L uh Lova Tim could you ask the guys
at Public Square about a feature to show
content creators and social media users
who share our values that is a very very
good idea I think they mentioned
something about that right I don't know
uh we'll bring it up to him that would
be really great I think there was talk
of some social component as well uh and
there should be yeah a way to interact
with people um obviously I think there's
reviews and comments already so
expanding that would be great but I
think you might be able to just apply to
be honest if you run a business that
produces something you probably should
be able to sign up for Public Square
that's what I did I I had to fill out an
application for we are change. shop for
my uh vitamins I put them on there and
um you know he means I have an I have
americanmade products but they mean you
personally for your YouTube channel huh
I think that's a good idea and I think
they should do that yeah so you can find
content creators who agree with American
values I like Public Square guys
download that app it's an excellent tool
for winning the culture War where are we
at what is
this JJ RH say anybody ever heard of the
Zid Door Church place is Wilding what is
that
no no no idea but thank you for the
Super Chat Lea Hagen says in a 60
Minutes interview yesterday Michael
Lewis just revealed that SPF tried
paying trump5 billion not to run in 2024
that true well I heard that he made an
offer for Trump not to run and that they
received a number that might have been
five billion they don't know who they
received the number from if it was from
Trump directly from someone knew if it
was even a real offer no one knows but
if you're Trump you obviously think
you're you're getting set up here
obvious
what'll happen is you'll say yes and
then they'll publish a leaked message
saying Trump took a payoff for billion
yeah that's like really really federally
danger like I would say illegal anyway I
don't want to go too deep on that but to
try to a politician to it happens every
day in Washington DC Ian every single
day all right Tina cullet says please
explain how if we can't afford to fund
our own country how and why should we
fund someone else's country oh I
actually actually have a a a I can
answer this for you
the idea is as the brics Nations attempt
to supplant the Petro dollar with the
WAN or now they're doing their own
bricks currency the US needs to maintain
confidence in the US dollar and how do
they do that by giving it away seriously
the reason why they give money for like
Pakistani gender studies is so that
Pakistan is looking at a pile of cash
China comes over and says hey use ours
instead and they're like look if we keep
using the US Dollars we get free money
we get to be rich these idiots keep
printing it yeah so the way it works is
you get ripped off as a regular
working-class person the elites who run
various countries agree to use the Petro
dollar which maintains us Petro doll
Supremacy and that's why we're funding
the war in Ukraine and giving money away
well
that yeah right I I agree with the Maga
method I think that's a better way to do
it you secure your borders you bring
manufacturing back you bolster the US
economy and then you win through trade
means and people are inspired to use
your currency because your currency
means something in this country so
what's the US doll dollar good for
coming to America is also and I want
dollars to spend so people will buy
dollars from you instead of getting them
for free but the US method is give them
the money tell them to use it they'll
get to be rich and if they don't we'll
come and remove their president that's
the current method not a big fan of that
one all right Deus Flex says when is
stick six and ammer coming on the show
bring him on before he leaves the states
again uh I have no idea I think we're
trying to make it work just yeah do we
have a date for him
uh yeah okay I don't know we were
supposed to do that show show in Upstate
New York a long long time ago it was me
and you we were driving up I think we
were going to Canada weren't we supposed
to meet up with him in Upstate New York
I have no idea that was a long long time
ago STI was one of the first people to
use mins like celebrity well-known video
bloggers that dude's tapped
in let's grab some more Super chats Jon
Jones says taking the new bright Line
train from Orlando to come see you guys
in Vice City can't wait for a fun time
oh it's going to be so amazing yeah how
how amazing that that Florida built the
bright line so now you can go from
Orlando all the way down here to Miami
they're going to build another Branch
that's going to go from I think Orlando
to Tampa basically you're going to it's
it's a train highspeed train and they
did it in basically no time it's clean
it's new it just launched it just
launched last week I was going to take
it yesterday coming back from Orlando
but something popped up but this is
funny all the things the leftists
demanded it's Trump it's the SST who who
have brought about like when uh they've
talked about we want a 4-day work week
we want better wages we want Healthcare
under Trump in 2019 there were all these
new stories about fast food chains
reducing the hours increasing the pay
and giving benefits and I'm like well
the Republican president gave it to you
now you've got all the leftist being
like where's the high-p speed rails like
well you know in Florida it's not in
California which they how much have they
put into that freaking thing like
something like3 billion I think they
spent the same amount of money building
the rail here as they did putting up
suicide Nets around the Golden Gate
Bridge in San Francisco I think it's
true that was $500 million I think yeah
and I think we spent the same amount
building here in Florida the Orlando to
uh to Miami 4 billion was that the
number B 3 to 4 billion probably cheaper
I want to know what the California one
has cost I'm going to look that up they
don't have it they need it they don't
have it and they started before they
have a greyhound it's yeah well you know
at
least all right antipathy says I agree
with a Sunday show caller that I would
like to see a live show of timcast on
Rumble you had your excuses and I can't
say that they aren't valid but why not
solidarity stream uh solidarity is not
as important as victory I guess I don't
know solidarity matters in a lot of ways
but that's like saying leave the
battlefield so you can go celebrate with
people who are no longer on it you could
think of it as a sort of
decentralization because if something
happens to rumble something happens to
rumble but we we we put all of our Clips
on Rumble we use Rumble infrastructure
for Tim cast.com we use parallel economy
for our timcast memberships it is all
Rumble cloud and then we just have the
live show on YouTube because it's the
it's consistently the biggest every
night and we want to get at access to
the generations younger Generations that
use YouTube and be in the central
Battlefield by the way we didn't talk
about this ton you guys hear this
Canadian legislation they just jam
through where they want to like police
any Network that has any kind of what
what's the terminology do you know the
word well basically anyone who creates a
YouTube channel I mean that's where it's
really going is going to have to
register with the Canadian government
and then God only knows what once you
register with them what they can do to
you to shut you down Europe is passing
similar legislation but CNBC has a very
interesting article about California's
highspeed rail uh and reporting that
it's running out of money and for 15
years that it's being built there hasn't
been a single mile of track laid from
the rail in California people are evil
Gavin new's going to be president what a
corrupt what a world that's how corrupt
here's what you got to watch out for
Dave you see what happens is California
takes off building this big Empire this
entertainment industry and they went
there originally to get away from the
oppression and the taxation they said
we're going to go to the middle of
nowhere where there's nothing and do our
own thing that's typically how pioneers
do it then once they got success in
wealth everyone else started crowding
around saying gim me Florida is starting
to do real well sooner or later you're
going to get a lot of people are going
to want to move in they're going to say
give me that no that's true that that
what a great challenge that is so now we
have to be better than say California
was once it you know California was a
was a repon there was a guy named Ronald
Reagan who was the governor of
California right like there was a
California conservative I think 1992 was
the last one uh that sounds about uh no
no cuz Schwarzenegger was a republican
oh no no but I yeah I'm thinking
president
um but anyway point is yes it's a
challenge and it's a function of success
right like Good Times create weak men
and you guys know the thing so it's like
Florida will have that challenge more
people will come here and then you have
to work harder to uh to defend those
rights and defend the good life
basically yeah Tron 54 says a Luke per
day keeps the Sheamus away damn right we
don't want that dirty Potato Man
anywhere near here well he's on his way
over really yeah are you kidding me no
okay good wait no wait you're you mean
you're you're
no he's coming he's he's coming he's not
welcome here heed
him I'll deal with the I'll deal with
the potato man later he called us and he
was like I've got potatoes for Luke and
I was like come on man he he messaged me
too he was like you know let's finally
do the show we were supposed to do and
I'm like uhhuh I literally just texted
him we were supposed to do a show
together and then he ditched on me last
minute oh sounds like Sheamus very
disappointed in but that was they were
doing the Potato Festival just kidding
Sheamus no there was no potato FAL I
would have excused him doing a Potato
Festival for not doing a show with me
together but but that's a different
issue again well be expect some
fireworks cogin coming in hot
yeah all right what do we got what is
this um Cory Corey USMC says working on
my birthday but I have some homegrown
chicken tenders in timcast IRL happy
birthday and that sounds amazing
homegrown chicken
tenders yeah amazing I've got a video I
recorded today about a rooster named
Andre about what it means to be a man
you Andre gave it all Andre I tweeted
about this he was a rooster who
sacrificed himself fighting off a
raccoon to save his hens how many you
got now uh too many 30 uh more than that
but at two different locations now so
probably like I think 90 do you guys
have chickens we had three backyard
chickens I had blanch feo prin Princess
Leia and uh who was my third chicken uh
is it Kim Kardashian or they were we we
had we nailed it with the name we have
Margaret Hatcher that's good that's
pretty good feather loer that was
another one we just we just gave only
like the original chickens that we got
man it's crazy we got seven and now we
have an an obscene amount uh Roberto the
original rooster his son died Roberto
had a heart attack and died suddenly we
don't know what happened but he has uh
Roberto junor had several kids so now we
have uh rp3 Roberto Jun Roberto thei
third nice and uh it's unfortunate cuz
Roberto them use phones or what no no
too young in fact we're not we're
actually quite concerned they are making
more of themselves and would like them
to stop but they've started doing that
you know we did incubate a bunch but now
they've started taking it upon
themselves to make more of themselves
and we we're not we're not too too fond
of that cuz life finds a way dude too
many Jurassic Park there's I mean it is
really amazing when one day you go in
there and you hear cheaping and then
there's like a you know chicken sitting
there all flat and like looking at you
and yelling at you and there's Babies
it's wonderful and then they walk around
they follow the mom and they're eating
you do know what happens to an egg under
the right circumstances absolutely can
become a chicken it's it do it's crazy
uh and you can you can you can eat them
you see at this period where you can eat
them in the egg or you got to wait you
know what like N9 months after the egg
but there's that period where you can't
some people eat the the raw baby chicken
not raw not raw I don't know ra you
ferment it they take the egg when when
the chick's fully developed they vinegar
and then bury it in the ground and then
wait a month and then eat it rotten or
whatever Belo yeah in the Philippines
they all the time y Balo blo yep yeah
but uh I was reading something about
people in like the Arctic Circle eat a
lot of rotten meat because the meat
itself doesn't have enough nutrients but
the bacteria festers on it and produces
more of the things you need then you eat
it rotten it's better for you I don't
know if that's true I but that's
something to do with why they do stuff
like
that here we
go what is this one
uh Lurch says BDS is banned in
government work hardly 1A friendly oh
that's in Florida right what was the
what was the deal with that I think
there was there was a Banning of
criticism of Israel on college campuses
which I think it's I think it's like an
oversimplification of what it actually
exactly yeah but but there was very you
know that is very troubling legislation
there also is a red flag I don't think
it was criticism of Israel I think it
was companies that were singling out
Israel that they were Bo Israel so so
yeah but but still to me I I don't like
that I don't like the red flag laws I I
think we should also criticize the state
and try to make it as as we can all
right dick Dickerson says sorry Luke
Florida isn't the Alamo my free state of
Missouri does more for freedom I don't
know about that moving maybe we don't
pay enough attention to Missouri I I
could concede that you don't talk about
Miss I don't know about that they
arrested the m mosis y oh right yeah and
St Louis and then he ran for Senate I
guess that didn't work out oh yeah yeah
yeah well there you
go all right dinner mint says hey Tim I
love your show I work for a company that
will be starting a coffee and soda shop
in Arizona I know the owner very well
it's possible for me to connect you
through Discord uh yes by all means and
uh you know a couple of things we want
to do obviously we're getting started
with the uh uh launching the first
coffee shop then setting up the
corporation and doing all paperwork to
properly franchise it but uh we also
want to distribute we could have you
know stores carry Casper coffee and you
know whatever if not setting up a your
own when we are able to you know there
we go let's uh let's grab some more
Super chats
what is this what is this someone
yelling about Luke I don't know what
they're saying they're just saying I
just joined Luke hi it's me not that
means anything Hi Ian hi all right Ryan
job thanks for the Super Chat thanks Ry
hey Ryan Stephen says says Madison
cauthorne exposed Kevin Mami two years
ago and look what they did to him really
what did he do with McCarthy with
McCarthy I don't know I remember he did
that whole thing about it there all
having coked up
orgies I don't know that he mentioned
McCarthy specifically
I want to I want to talk to Kevin
because you've said you've interviewed
him a couple times hope because I get
the vibe of the Trudeau vibe from him
lately like he's talking like this oh
his aect his A's a little bizarrely soft
or something but I can tell you how yeah
it's a little bit of Cali from the way I
mean from interviewing him like I my gut
sense with him is he's just trying on
the margins it's just not the most Brave
thing but he thinks he's trying to do
some like I don't think when people are
just like ah he's just an evil sellout
like I just think it's too easy to do
that the guy is he wants I from what I
could tell he kind of wants to live in
the same country we all want to live
he's trying to do what he can on the
margins maybe maybe it's not good enough
maybe it's completely ineffectual but I
don't think he's like you know the worst
of the worst in that sense what do we
got Steve Wanamaker says can we discuss
the fact that all Chase debit cards
aren't working and online accounts are
not showing balances I don't understand
how this is into bigger story people are
stuck on grocery store lines for real is
that happening right now I have not I
haven't heard it I haven't seen it I
don't use Chase yeah they just had to
pay a fine over helping EP was that what
it was yeah so maybe no money left maybe
I won't use that bank anymore and I'll
avoid uh yeah wouldn't that be something
though if that's actually a story and we
haven't none of us have heard of it and
they also punished a lot of people for
their political beliefs and expressions
and they shut down people's bank account
um yeah don't banquet JP Morgan and
Chase if you have if you don't have to
this is a Chase Bank customers report
account glitches again from seven hours
ago but this think advisor.com sure
interesting Clint tour says howdy people
sorry I'm late but I got stuck in my
zipper uh oh Ian looking good bro Luke a
true Florida man has a mullet but Mr
Dave gets a pass because he's too
stylish for that stuff Mr Dave can I
please get a I
agree I
agree well Sheamus will be here it's
been a long time it's been a long time
wait what was it Freedom tunes right
that's the freedom Tunes yeah that was a
long time ago what a what a world what a
world are you less agreeable now I think
so I'd like to think think so I didn't
even think I was that agreeable then it
was just one of those things that just
became a thing you know I was listening
to people talk but but but it wasn't
real and what Sheamus said was it was
just one time I think what he said was
he heard you say I agree and thought you
said it an interesting way so he wanted
to say it a lot oh oh that's good to
know you know what's funny people when
that thing first went crazy people were
like Dave are you upset and I was like
are you crazy like like first off I love
all these people this thing is about my
show it it means that we've done
something even if it's partly making fun
of me or they think I'm too soft of an
interviewer or whatever I was like this
is the greatest thing ever it's like
it's great I did I did some other thing
with him after that I forget what it was
actually if Shamus made a joke about
Rick Williams who said that's my mom
nobody would click it nobody would care
and they'd be like I don't what is this
the fact that everybody knew you and
understood the ref I thought it was the
greatest thing ever I people tell you a
lot but you kicked the door open on this
stuff like early like 2017 you Peterson
br
Weinstein like the IDW whatever has
happened in drama crap like you guys
grabbed it and shredded it I'll
tell you I spoke to Brett Weinstein
while driving over here today I'm as
good as ever with JP I'm going to do his
Arc conference in London at the end of
the month a few of the guys have stayed
saying you know Sam Harris kind of went
off the deep end and some of the others
kind of kind of lost it um but yeah I
mean I I was just kind of early on
trying to make sense we have no people
trying to make sense and that's all I
was really trying to do and I guess now
we're in a major sense deficit so it's
come around Thomas tjg says I'm in
California they allow them to vote there
are areas where they hand out ca IDs and
phones allowing them to register to vote
send journalists in Hemet and atanto
area you'll find them real quick just
drive around you know uh okay you you
remember Colin morari do you know Colin
yeah Colin uh he moved to Virginia got
the hell out of Cali and he was getting
I think for several years uh voter voter
ID you know to vote ballots in Virginia
to vote in California like how much more
do you need to know they're literally
sending them out of state for people who
have left California yep like crazy yep
there was that famous uh was that Fox
news story where a dude was from I think
what is he from Tennessee or from
Arizona he was like he was like from
Tennessee in Arizona and then they sent
a mail and vote to his house or they
claimed he voted he was and he was like
I'm not there I'm in college I'm I'm
states away makes you wonder man makes
you wonder can I read one yes the MC Glo
code says Dave and Tim if you each buy a
new chicken you could name them Tim
poultry and Dave ruen
ruen I'm going to get chickens when I
have when I get chickens those will be
the first my chickens when I get them
that's pretty good that's got to be a
rooster you got to be two roosters
though yeah that's right you know now
it's trendy to uh change genders not
there's anything wrong with that
roosters actually don't really fight
it's like a myth so we've got town
I was going to say there's a joke
here go for it well you know it's just
we got chicken City we got Town
toown is where we put all the extra
roosters cuz we you know I want to eat
them but my brother doesn't want to eat
them so we just don't but uh they they
they do fight sometimes but mostly just
get along it's when you in if you take a
bunch of roosters and put a girl in
there then they fight to the death just
those I don't know that they still do it
but like that collection of losers that
was always making videos about me and
you they're going to totally they're
going to totally grab that one Tim Po
wants to eat in town or whatever
like I mean d I'm do it in Time Square
we put up a 90 foot a 95 foot tall
picture of my on one of the biggest
uh beautiful Roberto Jun yes no no no I
I'm familiar with the internet we really
did put Roberto Jr on a 95 foot tall
billboard in Time Square and you want to
ban that on Twitter really makes
you it's a rooster day I got it I got it
I don't want to ban roosters in fact I I
strongly encourage people get more
roosters in fact I think people should
tell the story of Andre the rooster to
their children to inspire them to be
courageous and to understand the value
of sacrifice that's right yeah but that
video I recorded ear today is going to
be up on Friday and it's how to be a man
you got to learn from a
rooster all right uh the MC glone say uh
code says Tim or Dave here's a pair of
chicken names for you John lenen and
yolco
Ono it's hard to follow the other one
because it was personalized you know
yeah Pony up says get Colin Mor morard
on the show I think we were trying to
book him ago we you never did well yeah
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net
and town right right Lucen
filter.com is uh my website three master
classes Forum members only shirt and an
in real life Meetup this October 8th 4
p.m. here in South Florida only for
members Luken filter.com Ian give us
some words of inspiration with your
personal health Journey um uh drink more
water drink water when you wake up in
the morning and if you got a pee or poop
do it don't wait your body doesn't know
it could just start to hurt if you don't
do it so let it out
good night everybody see you later it's
been a pleasure hanging with you Florida
men all right always a pleasure sirge or
I guess we'll just we'll W spurge I
don't know if you have my mic set up
yeah I do I just want on mute because
there's a lot of echo in here uh Luke
you should work on that uh anyways it
was good uh I appreciate meeting you
Dave thanks very much right on yeah all
right everybody we will see you all over
at timcast.net